THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WILL BE AND ABOUT SO.
THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE WILL
COME TO ORDER. A GOOD MORNING
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEES HERE IN
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY. TODAY I'M HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ONE OTHER
MEMBER DR PAN IS HERE WITH ME
AND CENTER MELENDEZ WE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND FOR
OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS WE-
REMIND YOU AND ASK YOU TO
PLEASE MEET YOUR PHONES
COMPUTERS. THIS WILL AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. WHEN YOU WANT TO
SPEAK PLEASE USE THE RAISE YOUR
HAND PROMPT. AND THEN AFTER
YOUR RECOGNIZED A POP UP WINDOW
WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU TO ON
MUTE. SELECT THAT BEFORE YOU
SPEAK START SPEAKING IN OUR IT
PERSON WILL PUT YOU BACK ON YOU
WHEN YOU WERE DONE. BUT TO
ALLOW THE ACCESS WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS. SHE THEM DOWN
SCREEN. THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TOTAL. TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
REMOTELY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY REMOTELY. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IS ALSO
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE. SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. PLEASE OTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU AGAIN
PLEASE. MUTE YOURSELF FOR ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM IN THIS ROOM
AND DURING THIS HEARING- AND SO
YOU MAY BE ASKED TO LEAVE IF-
IF YOU CAN FOLLOW ALONG. OR
YOUR PHONE LINE MAY BE
TERMINATED. WELL EVERY EFFORT
IS MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS WE ASK FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. AND IF YOU DON'T GET
A CHANCE TO CALL IN TODAY WE DO
INVITE YOU TO CONTACT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. IN TODAY'S
HEARING WILL REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. OF STATE
HOSPITALS NOW WILL BEGIN WITH
THE PRESENTATIONS I'M OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THIS SO
WE HAVE. TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HERE IN THE DEPARTMENT
WE HAVE HERE- STEPHANIE.
COULDN'T HOW DO I SAY THAT
CLINTON CLINTON DIDN'T. YOU
TELL ME. WELCOME I'M- GOOD
MORNING IT'S O'CLOCK THEN AND
ON THE STATE HIGH. I THINK I
STUMBLED ON IT ONCE. HE GOT IT.
I THOUGHT ABOUT GOING AND START
WITH THE UPPER THAT GOVERN
BUDGET PROPOSAL I THINK A TELL
OF ELEVEN DOLLARS AND FIFTY
POINTS PERCENT INTO POINTS FIVE
BILLION IN TOTAL FUNDING THE
PART STATE HOSPITAL OP. WHICH
IS ANYTHING OF HUNDRED NINE TWO
NINE ON FROM THE PRIOR YEAR IT
ALSO REQUEST FOR SEVEN SIX
POINT THREE MILLION PER CAPITA
OUT THE DEPARTMENT IS COST
OPERATES STATE COUNCIL ACROSS
LOCATE IN SAN BERNARDINO
FOLLOWING THAT THE TASK IN OUR
OWN BUTTON NORWALK THE
DEPARTMENT INTO WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ON WORK TO THE AND YOUR
FRIENDS COMMENCEMENT SPEAKER
FOR THE OR THE FOR WALL
HEARINGS AS INCOME AND FILE.
NOT GUILTY BY OF AN- SEXUALLY
VIOLENT OFFENDERS MENTAL THAT'S
FOR AND WE ALSO SERVICES FOR
MENTAL ILL AND FROM ARE AND IN
THE HAVE BEEN CERTAINLY MET AND
I'M THE LUNCH SHORT. OUR
PATIENTS IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
THESE ARE PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUALS. FROM THE STATE
HOSPITALS BACK INTO. LAST
FISCAL YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
SERVE JUST UNDER ELEVEN
THOUSAND PATIENTS AT TEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO IN THE CURRENT YEAR HOWEVER
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED A REDUCTION
IN CENSUS DATA IMPACTS SEVEN IN
ON THE SYSTEM. WHICH WE WILL
DISCUSS THE NEXT ITEM SO I
WON'T GO INTO THAT IN THE UPPER
L. AS IN REVISE WE COULD TO SAN
A SENSE THOUSAND SEVEN AND
FIFTY I NINE OTHER. BY THE END
OF THE FISCAL YEAR HOWEVER DUE
TO EMPOWER OF THE NIGHT. WE NOW.
THAT THAT CENSUS TO BE LOW BY
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MOVING THE
VICE- AS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
MERGING SIX WE INTEND TO RESUME
AFTER AND WE'RE WORKING ON OF
ANY. IT'S IMPOSSIBLE AS THE
PROPOSAL BE PRESENTED TODAY
THERE REALLY THREE I MEAN THE
FIRST IS HAVE BEEN NIGHT AND
SIGNET IMPACT. ON OUR OPERATE
THIS PAST YEAR A THE COSTA
THROUGH THE END OF THE HEALTH
EMERGENCY. THE SECOND AROUND
OUR CONTINUE DISCUSS AND
EFFORTS TO SIR INDIVIDUALS TO
THE DEPARTMENT AS IN TO STAND
TRIAL. AND THE THIRD IS BEST IN
THE STATE HOSPITALS BUT FOR
FUNDING TO FOR MAINTENANCE ALSO
IF YOU OUT. JUST FOR THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM OUR HOSPITALS ARE LARGE
CONGREGATE YOUR ENVIRONMENT WE
SERVE INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS WHICH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR SOME THAT WE
START TO FOLLOW THE STANDARD
INFECTION CONTROL PRACTICES OF
WEARING MASKS. MAINTAINING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE AND NOW
WATCHING. AND MANY OF OUR
PATIENTS ALSO HAVE COMPLEX
MEDICAL CONDITIONS. SO WE QUIT.
WE RECOGNIZE THE THREAT THAT
COULD BE 19% OF OUR SYSTEM IN
TEXAS. MEDICAID PRESS. OUR
RESPONSE REALLY CAN BE LOOKED
AT- COSTS FOR SPEAKERS AND THE
FIRST STAGE REALLY WAS OUR
NATIONAL. WHAT IT OUR FIRST THE
FIRST SIXTY DAYS LOOK LIKE AND
THIS WAS REALLY AROUND
RECOGNIZING THE THREAT OF THE
NINETEEN PRESENTED OUR SYSTEM
AND TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTIONS
MITIGATE THE REST. THE LAST
MARCH. WE'LL SEE NEARLY AGO NOW
TODAY I WE ACTIVATE OUR
DEPARTMENT EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER AND THIS WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING OCTOBER
NINETEEN AT THE STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY OUR SYSTEM MOVING
TOGETHER AS A SYSTEM LEARNING
TOGETHER IS THAT STAMP AND
ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGES OF
THE SYSTEM. WE HAD TO PREPARE
PROPOSED IN NINETEEN TO PROCESS
WE ARCHITECT HOSPITALS
INFECTION CONTROL TO THE- WE
NEEDED TO DO IT FOR OKAY. IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE ARE IS-
PART OF WHAT WE DO ON A NORMAL
BASIS SO WE HAD TO IDENTIFY AND
IMPLEMENT ALL OF THE INFECTION
CONTROL MEASURES TO ADDRESS
EACH OF THE FACTORS THAT HAVE
BEEN NINETEEN AND FIRST-
ADDRESS. THE POTENTIAL OF
COMING ON OUR PATIENTS ARE AND
VISITORS IN OUR SYSTEM. DURING
THE FIRST SIXTY DAYS WE-
SUSPENDED PEACE IN THIS. AND
WORK TO DO AND PROCESSES TO
SAFELY ADMIT. AND PARKS. WE
CREATED A MISSION NOT SURVEYS
UNIT TO BRING A HOBART THE NEW.
MARK PARTS TO TEST THEM AND OF
THEM OVER FRTY DAYS AND THEN
MOVED OUT ONCE THEY CLEAR AND
WE KNOW THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
OKAY WITH TO THE HOUSING
BECAUSE OUR HOUSING UNITS
DORMAN. ARMY THAT I'M AVERAGE
AND FIFTY BAD SEE. WE
IMPLEMENTED A DALE STAFF
SCREENING IDENTIFY STAFF
REPLYING OR SOMETHING OF
EVERYTHING. WE DEVELOPED.
PROTOCOL INCLUDE TEST
QUARANTINE AND ICE. ARE WE HAD
TO PREPARE SPACE TO SERVICE I.
UNITS TREATING NIGHT THOUSAND
PATIENT. AND SEPARATE SPACES
FOR. PATIENTS WORDS SO AND
SYMPTOMS UNDER INVESTING.
COMPANY DURING THIS TIME OF
BIRTH DAYS WE ALSO HAVE PROCURE.
AND I'M FROM OUR ALSO. A DEVOUT
TREAT PROTOCOLS FOR CO NINETEEN
PATIENTS AND FROM AND YOUNG
MEANING SANITATION. AND DEVELOP
PATIENT AND STAFF TESTING
STRATEGY AND CON. ARE TESTING.
WE ALSO. BUSINESS DURING THIS
TIME IN DURING THAT FIRST.
SIXTY DAYS WE BREAK. WE YOUR
WAY- ESTABLISHMENTS AND PREVENT
OTHERS IN PARKING AND ARE. AND
YOUR FIRST OUT AND THAT'S
CALIFORNIA RE OPENED AFTER THE
INITIAL STEP HOW MARTYRS AND WE
RE OPEN OR EMISSIONS WE DID
BEGAN TO RAIN ON SOME AREAS OF
THE STATE WHERE MUNITY
TRANSMISSION WITH HIGHER- STAFF
TESTING POSITIVE FOR COCAINE
NINETEEN AND THEN OUTBREAKS OF
PATIENTS IN POSITIVE THAT SOME
OF OUR HOSPITALS. AND THIS
REALLY TESTED THE INFECTION
FROM MEASURES THAT WOULD WORK
SO ACT QUICKLY TO PUT IN PLACE.
I WOULD MONITORED AND REVIEWED
EACH OPERATE WE CONSULTED WITH
EIGHT. OF THE HEALTHCARE FIRED
INFECTIONS TEAM THROUGHOUT
THESE OUTBREAKS ARE THERE AND
ACTION PREVENTION AS VISIT OUR
HOSPITALS AND TO OBSERVER
SPRING AND- OUR THOSE PROTOCOLS.
WE ALSO MONITORED. ON TRENDS
MAJESTIC STRATEGIES
ACCORDINGLY- DURING THIS TIME
WE EVEN HAD TO CHANGE
LABORATORIES VENTURE REGAINING
NINE ONE TEST RESULTS. WE
CONTINUE. TO EDUCATE OUR
PATIENTS AND OUR STAFF AROUND
THE PROTOCOLS AND A RESULT OF
ALL OF THE EFFORTS WE WERE ABLE
TO MITIGATE OR OPERATE IN
DURING SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER
THIS YEAR- WE HAD VERY FEW
POSITIVE PATIENT BASIS PROFIT
SYSTEM AND MOSTLY JUST THOSE
WHO ARE POSITIVE AT THE TIME
THAT. MISSION OR WHO WERE
CONTRACTING HELP AND WHILE ACT
OUTSIDE THE SAUDIS ONE THE MOVE
INTO COMMUNITY HEALTH STUDIES
IN. OUR TREATMENT. STAGED HAS
BEEN THE- OURS SO WE JUST LIKE
ALL ACROSS EXPERIENCE BIRDS I
THE- ENGINE. TIME FRAME IT
REALLY START AFTER THE THINGS
HOLIDAY WHERE WE STARTED TO SEE
ESTá. RAMP UP THE STOCK HAS
BEEN BECAUSE- AND THEN FOLLOWED
BY PAGE AREN'T TESTING. THIS IS
FIRST NINE WE HAD OUTBREAKS
OCCURRING ALL FIVE POSSIBLE OF
THE TIME. THAT ARE MISSING
OPERATES WERE AFTER THREE
HOSPITALS LOCATED IN THE AREAS
OF THE STATE THAT WERE MOST
IMPACTED BY. BEING ON PATTON
STATE HOSPITAL THAT'S LOCATED
IN ST BERNARD DINO METROPOLITAN
STATE HOSPITAL IN LOS ANGELES
AND ARE CALLING A STATE
HOSPITAL IN THE FRESNO. AS WE
START TO SEE THAT SHARPENED IN
CASES FOLLOWING THE
THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY AND INTO
EARLY DECEMBER WE CANCELED IT
BUT PLAY WITH THE TESTING TASK
FORCE TO DETERMINE IF THERE IS
ADDITIONAL STRATEGIES WE COULD
PUT IN PLACE. AND BY MID
DECEMBER WE BEGAN. IMPLEMENTING
DALY ANTIGEN TESTING OF OUR
STAFF I WITH THE DAILY
INCIDENTS FASTING WE WILL. NOW
WE'RE ABLE TO PRO ACTIVELY
IDENTIFY DALY ALL OF THE EIGHT
SYMPTOMATIC BECAUSE THE STAFF
AND LINDA FROM WORK. NOT REALLY
HAS BEEN THE CHALLENGE WITH OF
THE NINETEEN BASS ARE THE IT'S-
INFECTIOUS NAS AS WELL AS THE
RATE OF- A SYMPTOMATIC
POSITIVES. MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY. AS A
RESULT OF THESE EFFORTS WEEK
QUICKLY STARTED TO SEE. A
DECLINE IN THE CODE RED
POSITIVE STAFF AND PATIENTS
ACROSS OUR FACILITY. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC THEM
THROUGH THE END OF JANUARY WE
HAD A TOTAL OF ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN
PATIENTS STATEWIDE WHO HAVE
BEEN POSITIVE FOR THE NINETEEN.
68% OF THOSE OCCURRED DURING
DECEMBER AND JANUARY STARTS OUT
REALLY WENT INTO. THE SYSTEM.
ALSO DURING THE SEARCH WE DID
EXPERIENCE STAFFING CHALLENGES
AND THAT'S WHERE WASN'T THE
RESULT OF THE HIGH NUMBER AND
STAFF AND FACTIONS- AND THAT WE
WERE EXPERIENCING WE DID WORK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. EMERGENCY
NURSING STAFFING. AND SURE THAT
WE WERE MEETING I'M NURSING A
REQUIRED NURSING RATIOS ALSO
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR STOP WORKING.
MANDATED OVERTIME. I WE HAVE
ALSO HAD TO THE- ADMISSION
DURING THE- OF THE START. AND
THIS IS BECAUSE WE WERE
EXPERIENCING I AM SO MUCH
BETTER WITH POSITIVE ACTIVITY
WHERE WE MET AND MOST OF OUR
HOUSING UNITS IT'S FINE WORK
FLORENTINE. AS WELL SO WE
REALLY COULDN'T MOVE ANY OF OUR
NEW EMISSIONS AND ZERO THE
HOUSING UNITS BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
WANT TO MOVE HEALTHY PATIENTS
IN THE HOUSING UNITS THAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN. THAT EXPOSED TO
NINETY AND TOM THEY ARE HOUSING
NO NO WASN'T I'M ACTUALLY.
THANKS FOR ROLLING BEEN OUR HIS
MILLION EXCITING TO BE A PART
AND IS OUR IN THE AND POSTS
OPERATION. WE BEGAN WESAID OF
THE- AT THE END OF DECEMBER.
AND INITIALLY PRIORE- BACK OR
HEALTHCARE WORK IN FURTHER.
MYSELF BASED ON IT STARTING
THOSE IN IN THE- H. AREN'T SO
WE I RECEIVED BATCHES AND BUT
THIS OUR FUTURE- STYLE. AND
THEN AS WE ARE LEAST MORE MORE
VACCINE NOW OF OUR STAFF. AND
WE ALL HAVE HAD ENOUGH THE FACT
TO ALSO FOR MADE ALL OF OUR-
ARE ALL OF OUR STAFF ALL EACH.
I HAVE BEEN ON THE BACK. AND
WE'RE- AT ABOUT AT SIXTY FIVE
OF AND EIGHTY OF. HAVE BEEN
BACKED STATEWIDE. I WERE NOW IT
AS SUCH YOU KNOW. RIGHT BACK AT
I WOULD THE COMMON NAY OF OUR
CAN EFFORTS IN DEAL ANSWER TEST
AND OUR BACKS. AND WE HAVE A
SURGE IN A ROW DEEP IN THE
POSITIVE EASTER IN RE WEEKS.
AND AS OF LAST- AND AS A TODAY-
WE ARE ARE TEN- WITH THE USER
NEW POSITIVE PATIENTS TO
PRACTICE OF THE NIGHT WITH THE
NURSES. I WE HAVE ONE PATIENT
WHO HAS BEEN POSITIVE AND IT
WAS A BRAND IN THE NATION THAT
WAS COMING IN FROM OUT PART
FRENCH. I WE ARE. AND THE PHOTO
ASSESSED. THE M. OF VACCINE.
MONITOR THE VERY IN CALIFORNIA
INSULTING WITH HEALTHCARE PARTY.
THEME RELATED TO WHAT OP
CHANGES WE CAN MAKE THEM FOR.
I'M A WANT TO TURN IT OVER NOW
THE DOCK WORK TO TALK- WORKED
OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BURDEN
MATT DIRECTOR OF HIGH. A COUPLE
OF ABOUT DATA. WE RECORD EVERY
DEATH PERCENT HAS HAD CO
NINETEEN IN THESE DATA AND WE
ALSO INCLUDE PATIENTS. THE
CONTRACTED THE VIRUS HAD AN
EXTERNAL FACILITIES SUCH AS A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY OR AN
ACUTE- MEDICAL HOSPITAL. WHERE
OUR MORTALITY RATE HAS
INCREASED BY POINT 38% 97% OF
OUR PATIENTS THAT PASSED HAD AT
LEAST ONE CDC DEFINED RISK
FACTOR WITH AGE BEING 83%
OBESITY IS 42% HYPERTENSION 41%
DIABETES TWENTY TWO PERCENT.
69% OF OUR PATIENTS ARE
PATIENTS THAT PASSED HAD TWO OR
MORE CDC DEFINED RISK FACTORS
AND 37% HAD THREE OR MORE. WE
ARE ALSO TRACKING THAT
SCHIZOPHRENIA SPECTRUM
DISORDERS ARE EMERGING IN THE
LITERATURE IS AN INDEPENDENT
RISK FACTOR. FOR MORTALITY
FROM- CODE NINETEEN AND 54% OF
THE PATIENTS THAT PASSED HAD A
SCHIZOPHRENIA SPECTRUM DISORDER.
WELL PERCENT OF THE- ARE WERE
IN AND IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY IN OUR FACILITIES 8%
WERE AN EXTERNAL SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY. SEVENTY EIGHT
THAT THE AVERAGE AGE WAS SIXTY
SEVEN POINT 3% AT 797% OF THE
PATIENTS THAT WE LOST- WERE
MALE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYTHING ELSE DIRECTOR AT
THIS POINT. NO THAT'S ALL THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO.
WHAT A JOURNEY HUH A YEAR AGO I
AT MY BIRTHDAY IS ON MARCH
THIRD WHICH ALSO HAPPEN TO BE
THE ELECTION LAST YEAR AND THAT
WAS THE LAST TIME. THEY WERE
OUT WITHOUT THESE OUT IN PUBLIC
AND I'M I'M JUST REFLECTING AS
NEXT YEAR'S MARCH MY BIRTHDAY.
ABOUT THE JOURNEY TO THAT WE'VE
ALL BEEN ON TOGETHER. AND I
CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE TRYING TO.
YOU KNOW JUST IN THE COMMUNITY
IT'S HARD ENOUGH TO KEEP TRYING
TO MAINTAIN SAFETY IN A- IN A-
IN AN INPATIENT FACILITY I
CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE. SO HOW DO
YOU THINK YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO SO MUCH BETTER THAN CITY RC
AS WITH THE SPREAD. AND
TRANSMISSION- RELATIVELY I MEAN
YOU STILL HAVE QUITE A FEW
DEATHS AND A LOT ABOUT BREAK.
BUT BUT YOU SEEM TO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO MITIGATE IT TO A
CERTAIN DEGREE CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT A LITTLE BIT. I CAN ONLY
SPEAK TO WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
IN OUR SYSTEM ON IN. THE YEAH
WE ARE HEALTHCARE ENVIRONMENTS
BY NATURE AND WE ARE ACUTE
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS YOU KNOW
WE PRIMARILY EMPLOYEE HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS. AS SO WE
ARE VERY DIFFERENT AND IN
ENVIRONMENTS- FROM CDC ARE. BUT
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW WE WORK
REALLY HARD AS A TEAM AND
COLLABORATING REALLY CLOSELY
WITH OPERATE DEPARTMENT. HEALTH
AND I WORKED. AND TO REALLY
DEVELOP PROTOCOLS AROUND ALL OF
THE FACTORS AS WE DISCUSSED ON
THE IN IMPLEMENTING INFECTION
CONTROL MEASURES. I WE EVEN
PARTNERED WITH CDC ARE EONS OF
THAT. ASSOCIATION AND IN EUROPE
I'M STATEWIDE. TO DEVELOP
PROTOCOLS THE BILL MENTIONED
THAT EARLIER AND TO DEVELOP
PROTOCOLS TO HELP THREE.
ATHLETES FRAMES FOR PATIENTS
BETWEEN OUR FACILITIES BECAUSE
WE DO SO MUCH OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE TREAT OUR
MOVE IN AND OUT OF THOSE
FACILITIES AS WELL. SO AND
THEY'VE BEEN GREAT PARTNERS IN
TRYING ZERO AND HELP. US AS
WELL AS THEM MITIGATE THE RISK
OF MOVING PATIENT. OR DID YOU.
DID YOU YOU AND I THINK YOU'RE
I THINK OF YOU DID THAT HAVING
STEPS TO IN HOTEL. IN ORDER TO
GET RID THE THIS AN ARRAY. WE
DID OFFER THE HOTEL I FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS. BIRDS AND
WE- ESTABLISH I'M IN. SUPPORT
LINE- OUR ONE OF THE AND I
STOCKS UP IS NOT A VERY. TIME
FOR STOPPED. I WE TOGETHER TEAM
SERVES AN EMPLOYEE SUPPORT LINE
AND ANY OF OUR STAFF THAT MAY
BE. I'M CHALLENGES AROUND I'M
HOPING NINETEEN AND ONE OF AND
THEY SERVICE BACK ON DO IT NOW
TO THAT HEALTH CARE FOR ANY.
EXCUSE ME HOTELS FOR HEALTHCARE.
WORKERS THEY NEED THAT. AND CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THE- VACCINATION
HAS. IN YEARS 265% SAID YES AND
THEIR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
FOR THE MOST PART HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT AND DO
YOU EXPECT TO SEE THAT CHANGE.
ACTUALLY AS WE SEE THE SAME
KIND OF. BEANS ARE BETWEEN BOTH
OUR STAFF AND OUR PATIENTS
WHICH IS NO DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IN THE
COMMUNITY REALLY WHICH IS AND
YOU HAVE YOUR EARLY ADOPTERS SO
WE CERTAINLY AYE WE HAVE PEOPLE
THAT WERE STANDING AT THE DOOR
WAITING FOR THAT VACCINE TO
COME IN THAT DAY WHEN IN THE
FIRST IN OUR LIVES AND THAT
REALLY WERE JUST SIGNING UP AND
EAGER TO GET IT. ARE YOU WE HAD
THOSE- WAIT AND SEE KIND OF
FOLKS LET'S SEE HOW THE FIRST
PEOPLE I RESPOND GET THEIR
VACCINE AND THEN YOU HAVE
INDIVIDUAL STORY AND TAKE BACK
IN A VACCINATION AND SO-
REGARDLESS OF THE OF WHAT
VACCINE IT IS THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THEY'RE INTERESTED IN
AND WE SEE THAT- FOR OUR
PATIENTS AS WELL SO I THINK
WORK WE CONTINUE TO EDUCATE OUR
PATIENTS AND OUR STAFF AROUND
THE VACCINE WE DEFINITELY
CONTINUE TO OPERATE. AS A WEED
IT WASN'T JUST A ONE TIME COME
GET YOUR VACCINE THE WORD
pTHAT PROCESS AND EVERY DAY WE
GET MORE AND MORE BACK THAN
IT'S BEEN I THINK IT'S JUST
GOING TO BE CONTINUING JOURNEY
WRITTEN. BACK PLEASE. OKAY M. I
HAVE WHAT I SEEM. ANIMAL IT HAS
OUR- I THINK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN
THINK YOU HAVE CLEARLY HAVE
YOUR HAND FULL AND- DIFFICULT
TIME HERE BUT- I AM JUST. TO
UNDER. WHY CDC ARE IS SENDING
CODED NINETEEN PATIENTS HERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE CAN YOU WALK ME
THROUGH THAT. BUT THEY'RE NOT
AND INTENTIONALLY SENDING CODED
AT NINETEEN POSITIVE PATIENTS
SO YEAH- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS AND MAYBE I CAN TURN
THIS OVER TO DOCTOR WERE
WORKING VERY. REYES THAT SHE'S
BEEN DOING A LOT OF WORK WITH
CDC ARE SENT THEY HAVE. A
PROCESS TO. A BEFORE THEY
TRAINING TO. OUR AND THEY HAVE
HI- FACILITY THAT HAVE BEEN
CLOSED IN MID MAY AND WHEN HAS
BEEN OUT IN THE HIS CELL THE
NOT. PATIENTS AND WEEK CLEAR
THEM TO. BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE
WERE OF THAT IN THE THIS IS
VERY. BUT NATURE OF HER NINETY
IS THAT YOU CAN BE EXPOSED AND
IT'S GOING TO BE CONTENT ONLY
UP TO FOURTEEN DAYS BEFORE YOU
BECOME POSITIVE. AND OR YOU MAY
BE A SYMPTOMATIC AND WE DON'T
KNOW YOU HAVE. AND SO THEY CAN
HAVE SOMEBODY SAY EVERYBODY'S
RECEIVED ITS HOUSE THE LAST THE
PATIENT AS PREVIOUSLY YOU KNOW
YOU CAN'T FORCE SOMEONE ASK BUT
THAT'S A VERY SMALL NUMBER. AND
BUT UNLESS THE- YOU KNOW THE
PATIENT COULD TEST ONE DAY
NEGATIVE. AND A COUPLE DAYS
LATER WHEN THEY GET TO OUR
MISSION OBSERVATION UNIT AND WE
TRUST THEM THREE TIMES WHILE
THEY'RE IN THE NATION
OBSERVATION UNIT SO ONCE UPON
ADMISSION. AGAIN I THAT SEVEN
DAYS AND AGAIN A WORKING DAY
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVEN'T-
AND DEVELOPED SILVA NINETEEN.
WE MOVE THEM INTO OUR HOUSE. SO
AND THEY CAN BECOME THROUGHOUT
THAT FOURTEEN DAYS BECAUSE THEY
WERE IN KEEPING AND NO ONE THEY
HAD BEEN IN. SO I KNOW DR WEBER
NAY ERRORS ON ANYTHING WORN
WANT TO. BACK IN- WHAT WHAT
TYPE OF TO THE BEING. BEFORE
THEIR TRAINING. THEY
SPECIFICALLY WENT TYPE OF DEAL
KEVIN CAST HE CAN. SO I AM CAIT-
IS TUCKER WRITTEN YOU LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT THE PROCESS BETWEEN
ARE. YES THANK HE WERE VERY
DIRECTOR MARTIN STATE FARM. AND
IT HAS BEEN AN ONGOING PROCESS
ISSUE AS WE DEVELOP STATE BURKE
FROM CALLS WITH WE ARE IN THIS
WAS AND- HI INTO OF HAVING A
FEW TRANSFERRED BY WEEK TAKE A
BASE. TO ANSWER YOUR NEXT-QUESTION IS SUB OF PATIENTS
FROM THE PART CORRECT WHO ARE
NOT A FAN THAT. WE
CLASSIFICATION AS THE DISORDER
AND IN THOSE WE HAVE NO. A BILL
TO PREVENT THE IN BARELY STATUS
IS THAT ARE PRO TWICE HONEST
DAY AND- AND THAT WAS THE WITH
THIS INTO BUT IT WAS A RARE AND
WE DO HAVE THIS STATE THAT AND
PROTOCOL THAT THAT TO ME I KNOW
THIS WE WERE ABLE TO ISOLATE
THE END OF THE OUT I'M HAVING
IT NOW GREAT. YES THIS DOWNTURN
MISSION OBSERVATION UNIT. FOR
FOURTEEN DAYS DURING THAT
SERIAL TESTING PROCESS AND
AFTER THAT- IN MISSION PROCESS
IS COMPLETED THEN THEY GO TO
THEIR- I TREATMENT UNIT SO THIS
WAS. AN UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCE IT
WAYS I. COMBINATION OF- THE
PERSON'S LEGAL STATUS AND JUST
THOSE THOSE ONE AND A MILLION
CASES WHERE WHERE THAT TESTING
PROTOCOL DID NOT CATCH THE
INDIVIDUAL UNTIL THEY GOT TO US.
YOU'RE A MUSICIAN- MELINDA'S.
SORRY THANK YOU YOU FEEL- THE
PROCESS NOW HAS BEEN REFINED
ENOUGH THAT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN. ABSOLUTELY
YES. THANK YOU IN CONNECTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OCTOPATH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I THINK
THE OTHER FOR YOUR- PRESENT AND
ALSO FOR THE HARD WORK YOU DID-
DURING COVE AND- TO TRY TO
CONTAIN THIS- AND THEN- WITHIN.
OUR STATE. I DO HAVE A FEW I
THE- FOLLOW UP ON- AND OF. THAT
THE TERMS OF. TRACING AS YOU
WERE. AT SO I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
LEVEL YOU'RE ABLE CONTACT
TRACING YOU HAD POSITIVES
WITHIN THE STATE HOSPITALS-
BUT- ARE YOU REACH YOUR GIVEN
THE HOUSES THAT YOU HAD. YOU
KNOW WHAT PERCENT PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE WERE RELATED TO VIRUSES
BEING BROUGHT IN FROM THE
OUTSIDE INTO THE HOSPITAL
VERSES INTERNAL SPREAD. SO SAID
SO IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW HOW THE
CASES HOW MUCH OF THAT WAS
BECAUSE AND DAYLIGHT AND
CERTAINLY NO YOU DID A LOT OF
EFFORTS TO TRY TO PREVENT
INTERNAL SPREAD BUT- YEAH. IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE THE- OCTOBER IT CAME
FROM- HOW HOW MUCH OF THAT WAS
INTERNAL SPREAD VERSUS SOMEONE
BRING IT YEP YOU BRING IN FROM
OUTSIDE SO WHETHER IT'S A
PATIENT TRANSFER R. OR- STAFF-
IT. GIVEN COMMITTEE RATES AT
CETERA- WITH CONTACT WE ABLE TO
DO ENOUGH DETAIL CONTACT
TRACING TO BE OLD A FIGHT. THIS
INFORMATION. SO WE DEFINITELY
DO CONTACT FOR YOU SEEN AROUND
EACH INTERACTION AND TO
IDENTIFY WHO WITH IN THE
FACILITY MIGHT. HAVE IF YOU. AT
IF AN INDIVIDUAL LET'S SAY AN
EMPLOYEE TESTS POSITIVE AND
THEN WE DEFINITELY DID A
CONTACT FREE SEEN A DENTIST
FIVE TWO I'LL THEY ARE. BEEN
INCOME. WITH I WITHIN OUR
FACILITIES AND GRAND I. THINK
THIS GUY SO- YOU SAID YOU TACAN
US WITH THE FIRST. BUT FOR
EXAMPLE YES WHO WORK AT THE
FACILITY SO THEY'RE ENTERED BUT
THEY ALSO INTERFACE WITH THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE SO ARE YOU
ABLE TO CONTRACT. YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU DO CONTACT TRACING IT'S ALL
THE CONTACTS IT'S NOT JUST SO.
YOU KNOW STAFF PERSON YOU DON'T
JUST CONTACT REYES WHO THEY GOT
CONNECTED TO WITHIN THE
FACILITY IT'S ALSO WILL BE
CONTACTED WHEN HE WENT HOME OR
WHEN THEY WENT SHOPPING AND
STUFF LIKE THAT SO WE WILL DO
THAT LEVEL CONTACT TRACING. SO
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CONTACT FOR YOU SEEN WITHIN OUR
FACILITY AND THEN THE PUBLIC
THAT THEY COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DOES THE RIGHT. THERE REMAIN.
IN PREDICT OKAY WELL- IN YOUR
COLLABORATION WITH YOUR LOVED
HEALTH THE- WERE YOU ABLE TO
GET THAT KIND OF. I REALIZE IS
THERE PRIVACY IS IN TERMS OF
ACTUAL PEOPLE BEING TO. FIGURE
OUT. WHERE YOU KNOW WE DE VIRUS
FROM WHEN YOU AN OUTBREAK IT'S
STILL TO BE A TO DO THAT.
SAREJEVO INTEGRATE THAT. I KNOW
I CANNOT TELL YOU WHAT FIRST
AND OF THAT CASES MORE INTERNAL
COURSES AND THAT THANK YOU VERY
DE TO GET TO PARTICULARLY WE
BRING OUT OF RATE OF TRYING-
YOU KNOW TRY AND TRANSFER WORK
ON OUR ON AB PARTICULARLY
DURING NIGHT OF DECEMBER AND
JANUARY FRAME- BUT WE DO
UTILIZE CONTACT FREEZING TO
REALLY TRY TO IDENTIFY WHERE
WITH THAT ARE. AS WE NEED TO
FOCUS OUR I CONTAINMENT EFFORTS
TO FOREIGN SINCE PAST AND- THAT
TO TEST I DON'T WE HAVE IN THAT
IS A OKAY SO I GUESS I WOULD
INCORPORATE HELP FOR PANDEMIC
AS MUCH AS DON'T WANT TO THINK
ABOUT AS WELL TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS ONE- WE SHOULD BE OF. OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTOCOL AND HOW
WE BUILD THOSE RELATIONSHIPS-
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
OPERATED. AND AND- SO- I THINK
THAT THOSE AT THE NAME IS MORE
ABOUT LESSONS ABOUT HOW WE- TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW DOES SO WE
CAN GET THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION SO IN THE FUTURE
PANDEMIC. HOPEFUL WE DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER SPIKE OF THIS ONE-
WE'RE CROSSING FINGERS WERE THE
VACCINE AND FORTH. BUT BE ABLE
TO THE FACT- NOW. WE HAVE TO
RELY THAT THE INSTITUTION ONSEN
BUBBLE HAVE STAFF THAT WORK AND
COMMUTE ARE THERE YOU HAVE
PEOPLE CAME. IN AND YET WE'VE
ACTUALLY PEOPLE TO. OUT AND SO-
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
BUILD THOSE RELATIONSHIPS- WITH
ORGANIZATIONS OUT. SIDE THE
INSTITUTION THAT MY IN DEPTH-
AND I GUESS THE- YEP THE NEXT
QUESTION I HAVE A APPRECIATE
AGAIN YOU PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION- I NOTE THAT YOU
SAID FIFTY FIVE PATIENTS HAVE
DIED SINCE MAY THIRTIETH I
DON'T KNOW IF THE REASON YOU
PICK MAY THIRTY IT'S BECAUSE
THAT WAS THE FIRST DEATH
VERSUS. OR ANY THAT'S PRIOR TO
MAY THIRTIETH SO MUCH OF WHAT
THE SO YOU CAN CLARIFY THAT BUT
HAVE WE ALSO IDENTIFIED WERE
THERE ANY DEBTS OF STAFF
RELATED TO OUTBREAKS- THAT
MIGHT HAVE ORIGINATED FROM
WITHIN THE INSTITUTIONS SO YOU
KNOW YOU'VE HAD- MANY POSITIVE
STAFF AND- PATIENTS- DESPITE
YOUR BEST EFFORTS- WERE THERE
DO WE KNOW IF ANY STAFF WHO
ENDED UP DYING. BECAUSE THEY
ARE EXPOSED. TO THE VIRUS WHILE
AT WORK. THOSE TWO THINGS FOR
ME. LIKE WANT TO I JUST GOT TO
THE FIRE. WRITTEN JUST FIVE
FIND WE DO WORK REALLY CLOSE
WITH OUR PUBLIC HEALTH. THAT
WERE NOT WORKING. A BAND
WORKING WITH US CONSOLE ARM.
INTERACTION AND- AND
TRANSMISSION WE'RE GONNA
HOSPITAL AND OUR OF THE TEAM AT
IN IN MANY AREAS HAVE. HAVE
WITH THE TEAM AT OUT PART IN
BACK TO SEE IF HAVE BEEN INTO
OUR FACILITY AND BY. AS WELL.
THERE DEFINITELY ESTABLISH
RELATIONS THE PERFECT PUBLIC
HEALTH PARTNERS THEY JUST
WANTED TO ASSURE YOU THAT THERE
IS THAT. COLLABORATION AT GOING
ON THE COMMUNITY. WE DO HAVE IN.
AND THAT OFTEN COMMUNITY THAT.
OPERATE IN RIGHT- BUT JEFF ON
THE. YEAH OKAY SO ARE YOU ABLE
TO SPEAK TO HOW MANY STAFF
MIGHT HAVE EITHER DIED OR BEEN
HOSPITALIZED BECAUSE EXPOSURES
AT WORK. FROM COVERED SO I KNOW
YOU GAVE YOU HAVE A STATISTICS
YOU PROVIDE ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
PATIENTS HAVE DIED- I NOTE THAT
YOU REPORTED ONE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED TEN STAFF TESTED
POSITIVE BUT DOING THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THOSE TEST
TESTING POSITIVE AND AGAIN THIS
GOES BACK TO YOU. I THINK MY
FIRST QUESTION AND I DO
APPRECIATE AND ENSURE THAT YOU
DO TRY TO WORK WITH THE PUBLIC
BUT I MEAN THIS IS TALK ABOUT
INTEGRATING THE INFORMATION
RIGHT SO YOU HAVE A HOSPITAL.
GRADE YES PEOPLE WHO WORK THERE
THEY LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY- SO
ARE WE INTEGRATING OUR DATA IN
A WAY SO THAT WE WOULD KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE I THINK THE
COMMUNITY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WANT TO KNOW IF
THERE WERE OUTBREAKS GOING
HOSPITAL IS THAT GOING TO CAUSE
OUTBREAKS GOING ON OUTSIDE AND
YOU DON'T INTELLIGENCE
OUTBREAKS IN THE COMMUNITY. ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING NOW
THEY'RE PICKING IT UP AND GO.
WHEREVER PLACE THEY ARE AND
THEN THEY BRING IT INTO WORK
IT'S ADDRESS SO- SO I GUESS YOU
KNOW IN RELATION TO THAT- OF
THE ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
TEN STAFF IT DID TO END UP
TESTING POSITIVE DAY IN THEM IN
THE HOSPITALIZED. OR DYING FROM
COATED. YES WE DID HAVE SOME.
IS VERY FEW HOW. AND- AS IN THE-
THREE. THAT THREE THREE THAT'S
OKAY ALL RIGHT SORRY- OKAY I
THAT MUST MISSED THAT OKAY AT
NIGHT IN THEN AGAIN YEAH I YOU
I THINK- THE IS NOT A- I. THAT
EVERYTHING USED TO TRY TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAY I'M JUST TO THINK OF
WHAT WE DO. TO THIS I CAN TELL
DISEASE RIGHT AND SO MOST OF
THESE OPERATE ARE GOING TO.
DISEASES AND- AS PEOPLE FROM
ONE TO AND- AND I KNOW THAT
YOUR MAIL IN CHARGE OF STUFF
YOU KNOW THE WORK THAT THAT THE
HAAS. PLACE THE ADAPTATION WHO
ARE RESERVE THERE IN THEN YOU
HAVE STAFF WHO WORKED- BUT
THESE PEOPLE CREEK MOVED BACK
IN FORTH- FOR. REASONS WE'VE
GOT A TO GET THAT KIND OF. AS
WELL AND AGAIN APPRECIATE
EXAMPLE YOUR- AND MELENDEZ
WHERE YOU YOU KNOW YOU YOU DO I.
AND SO FORTH TO TRY SPUR FIFTY
A PAGE CANCER IN OR OUT THAT'S
THAT'S RAMPS APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'VE DONE- BUT I IS JUST. ONE
TO GET A BETTER. OF HOW WERE.
IN IN THE RESPONSE THE END THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT. WHAT FOR THE-
ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE DO WE
HAVE THE DATA SAID. AND ARE WE
HAVING TO. AND DATA COLLECTION
PLACE BE ABLE TO. TRACK A
OUTBREAK THAT. KILLED I CAN
AGAIN. MOVE BETWEEN SETTING
BECAUSE YOU GOT MOVING BETWEEN
DIFFERENT SETTINGS AND THEY
NEED TO CARRY AND IN FACT AS
YOU MAY NOTE YOU KNOW
OFTENTIMES YOU FOR FIVE.
GRAYSON AND SO FORTH MAKES IT
TO TRACK. AND THEN THE OTHER
GET THE OTHER CAR. IS AND I
KNOW THAT'S FOLLOW UP. A EGGMAN
QUITE. IN TERMS OF. THE
VACCINATION STAFF TO. A PERCENT
THE PACE- HOPEFULLY WE GETTING.
TO CAN. HAVE THE PAGE. AT 80%
THE 60% RATES UNDER. WHEN YOU
THAT- DOES BUT- YOU KNOW YOU
FOR. DAY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE TO-
EARLY ADOPTER. IN ANY OF THE
PEOPLE. I WANNA WAIT AND SEE
AND SO FOR BUT- REACH TO GET
LEE SOME IN FOR. FROM THIS. AT
OF- IT'S IF THERE ARE. THAT WE
CAN TRY TO DO TO HELP ADDRESS
ANY CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS THEY
HAVE SO THAT- SO THAT THEY
WOULD TOTALLY BE. MORE
ACCEPTING OF- THE VACCINES ARE
AT LEAST ADDRESSING ANY
CONCERNS THEY HAVE AND IN
SUBSEQUENT ROUNDS OF- OFFERING
VACCINES TO. THE STAFF SO WE
CAN ALSO GET THE RATE IN THE
STAFF. ARE CLOSER TO THE 80% WE
GOT TO THE PATIENTS. THOSE AT
IT HAS BEEN SOME- WORK BEING
DONE IN THAT AREA. IN TERMS OF
WHAT KIND OF ADDITIONAL THINGS
THAT. THE STAFF. NEED TO KNOW
OUR INFORMATION OR OTHER
BARRIERS FOR THEM TO I GUESS
ACTUALLY FOR THE REMAINING- A
PORTION OF THE STAFF. BUT YEAH
ACTUALLY I'M GONNA START THE
WORKING MIKE ABOUT BECAUSE- WE
HAVE AND- ENGAGING AND- I'M NOT.
CONGRESS AND FIND UNDERSTAND
HOW TO DO. AND AT. I HAVE
TRYING DIFFERENT PROPER WITH
YOU IT BROUGH OUTDOORS. SO AND
WILL BRING YOU WANT AND- FOR
THEIR MARKET. SURE AND WE DO IT
IN OF. OUR REACHED WE DID. WE
WEATHER AFFECTS ME WITH HER
STAFF DO JUST A- SPECIFIC
MEETINGS IN THEN WE DO A LARGE.
NAY KIND OF WITH A OF OUR- TO
WE TAKE. THAT THEY- AND THEY
DETAIL QUITE. ABOUT VERY AND SO
BOOST. AND SO WE GATHER ALL OF
THAT IN. AND ALL OF THOSE. AND
WE THAT AND- OUT WE HAVE PANELS
ON OUR WEB AXES OF PEOPLE. WHO
RECEIVED THE VACCINE YOU KNOW
IF A QUESTION COMES UP. YOU
KNOW I'VE TESTED. POSITIVE FOR
COCAINE IN THE PAST SHOULD I
GET A VACCINE LARGELY BRING IN
A STAFF PERSON WHO'S- BEEN
THROUGH THAT SITUATION TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT IT FELT LIKE. FOR
THEM SO WE ARE VERY ENGAGED
WITH OUR CLINICAL STAFF TRYING
TO. GET THROUGH SOME OF THE
BARRIERS RELATED TO VACCINE
HESITANCY DUE TO- CONCERNS OR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SAFETY OR
EFFICACY OF THE OF THE VACCINE
ITSELF. I'VE ALSO PARTICIPATED
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
NATIONAL MEDICAL DIRECTORS
COUNCIL AND WE HAD A BIG- TO
THAT PART. OF THAT MEETING%
ABOUT VACCINE HESITANCY WITH
SOME- BEST PRACTICES SHARED-
ONE OF THE BEST PRACTICES I
LEARNED- FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THAT. OUR GROUP IS A PROCESS
WHEREBY WE NOW ARE SCHEDULING.
ALL OF OUR STAFF WHO IS NOT
YET. BEEN VACCINATED TO COME
IN- EITHER TO- I GET THE
VACCINE OR. TO ASSIGN A
DECLINATION FORM SO THANK YOU
US ENOUGH. TO THOSE FOLKS ARE.
NOT COMING IN NOT OVER THE OF
SCHEDULING POINT IF YOU. OKAY
GIVE THE CITY TO HAVE A ON ONE
HER GROUP HIM A- AND- THAT'S
ACTUALLY REQUIRED BAD IT
WHENEVER FACILITIES. THAT'S
BEEN VERY SO WE'RE IN THE- OF
NOW. OUT THROUGHOUT DIDN'T SEE
AT THE- NINETEEN PER AMERICAN
STAFF. BASICALLY SAID I'M NOT
GOING ACCEPT VACCINE UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES- BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO WORK THROUGH THE THAT REST
OF THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE. LATE
ADOPTERS BUT NOT COMPLETELY
AGAINST IT OKAY NOT THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT AND CERTAINLY
THAT SHOULD BE THE NEXT A-
GROUP OF PEOPLE WORKING ON IT
WOULD BE INTERESTING TO FIND
OUT WHAT. THE THAT REMAINING
1019% WHAT LATER ON- THAT'S NOT
THE PRIORITY IS TO. YOU KNOW
WHAT REASON AND- IT IS WE TRY
TO DRESS A- THIS IS. THAT IS
OFTEN ABOUT. SO I JUST YOU KNOW
I DO WANT TO SERVE AND BY-
RECOGNIZING THAT- USE THAT YOU
KNOW YOU CAN USE A DRESS A VERY
DIFFICULT CHALLENGE YOU'RE
RUNNING THESE. ESSENTIALLY
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES- AND
AT PANDEMIC. AND AND THAT- YES
CERTAINLY ALL THE HARD WORK
YOU'VE DONE THE THINGS THAT HAD
TO DO TO TRY TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF THIS- THIS- DISEASE-
EVEN AS IT WAS RAGING OUTSIDE-
YOUR FACILITIES AS WELL AS WE
TALKED ABOUT PEOPLE MOVE BACK
AND FORTH AS WELL AND- IT BEGAN
FREESHEET ALL THE HARD WORK I
KNOW THE NEXT ITEM WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN AS WELL- BUT I DO JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT- YOU AND
YOUR STAFF CERTAINLY OF THE-
WORKED VERY HARD AND AS- AS-
I'VE TRIED TO DO- YOU KNOW AND-
YEAH. IMPLEMENTS SOME- RATED
THINGS- TO TRY TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF A VERY SERIOUS
DISEASE AND- AND- AGAIN
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
AND SUCH ALSO TRYING TO. IT IS
ALWAYS AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
FROM THESE EXPERIENCES
HOPEFULLY WE NEVER HAVE TO
REPEAT- ATTENDANT MAKE BUT I
THINK- WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
A POSSIBILITY IN THE FUTURE AND
SO EACH TIME- HOPEFULLY WE
LEARN A LITTLE MORE YOU CAN DO
A LITTLE BETTER- BUT AGAIN I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE HARD
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE- THIS.
YEAR YEAH THIS PAST YEAR AND A
LOT OF VERY GOOD WORK TO WAS
WELL SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO PASS. AM FOR MOVE
ON KID. CAN YOU JUST TALK
LITTLE BIT OF. ABOUT YOUR STAFF
I KNOWS HOW HARD THIS MUST HAVE.
ON THE STAFF THREE WHAT. HOW
ARE THEY- WHAT WHAT HAS IT COST
ISN'T WHAT DO YOU THINK ARE
GOING TO BE LONG TERM OF
IMPACTS GOING FORWARD AND WILL
THAT ALSO. AND PEOPLE HAD TO
BRING IN- OUTSIDE AND I'M SURE
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF SICK TIME
AND I'M SURE THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF OVERTIME AND- ALL THE THINGS
THAT IMPACT. OF THE BUDGET BUT
ALSO THAT ARE IMPACTING. YOUR
STAFF LIVES TO CAN YOU SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. HOW YOUR HOW
YOU'RE BALANCING THAT AND WHAT
KIND OF SUPPORT YOU THINKING
THEY GOING FORWARD. CERTAINLY
AND I WILL ALSO PROBABLY COLLIN
DOCTOR WILBURTON ALSO TECH. TO
TALK- OR TRAUMA. INFORMED CARE.
TO THE PANDEMIC- BUT JUST FROM
OUR AND THEN THERE WAS. WAS MY-
AND GENDER. THERE ARE. I DIDN'T
RESPOND TO. COSTS AND- AND-
FROM THE COST FIRST. WE WERE A-
TO. AND THEY. PRIOR FISCAL YEAR
OBSERVE THE COST RELATED TO
COVER NINETY WITHIN OUR EXIST
NEXT. WERE STILL OF FINAL AND
THAT KIND OF THE WAY WE
ANTICIPATE CURRENT YEAR TO BE
THANK CAME SO. A THIS LAST YEAR
THE SERVER. SO WORST WORKING ON
THAT I KNOW ALL- COSTS- BUT DO
NOT THAT THE- LAST S. WE HAVE
WAS MOREEACH TWO NINE DOLLAR
IN THE CURRENT YEAR. THAT WAS A
PRESENTER BY I KNOW I IN
NOVEMBER AND- RESPECT FEDERAL-
WE- WE ARE WORKING TO. RECEIVE
MY REIMBURSE FROM FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YOUNG FOR THE
REIMBURSED AND REALLY. AND SO
WE CONTINUE TO WORK TO MATTER
TEST BLAMES AND AS SOON AS
THOSE ARE WALLS THE MAP ALL OF
OUR ANTICS. AND WORKED AS MUCH
AS WE CAN IN FACT I'M FROM THE
FEDERAL- WITH RESPECT THE- ON.
THE STOCK BEEN I GOT TO SAY FOR
YOUR IN IMPACTING THE AND WITH
PATIENTS THEIR WELL IT'S BEEN A
VERY YEP. TIME RIGHT IT'S BEEN-
WORKING IN A- ENVIRONMENT AND
JUST WHAT WE WHO HAVE TO GO
INTO THE HOSPITAL EACH DAY WHAT
WOULD YOU. OUT IN COMMUNITY-
THAT IS X. RAY- MADE MUCH DEPTH
WORKING IN THEY WERE LIVING IN
A CONGREGATE CARE ENVIRONMENT
AND WAS DEFERRED DURING THE TO
SOME ENGINE. START WE- HAVE
DEFINITE ONLY AT TO THE STAFF
IS MUCH AS POSSIBLE I TALKED
THE- EMPLOYEES. LINE WHERE YOU
HAD A FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
FOOD TO PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN.
WE'VE YOU KNOW THERE'S NOT A OF
THINGS THAT THAT AND DONE I TO
HELP REALLY ARE. SUPPORT THE
STAFF AS MUCH AS WE CAN- WE
ALSO. HAVE. AND EVERITT SAID DR
WARBURTON TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT AS WELL. THANK YOU
AT WE ARE FORTUNATELY ABOUT
FIVE YEARS AGO BECAME A TRAUMA
INFORMED SYSTEM WORKING WITH
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE SO TO SOME EXTENT
HAD- ASSIMILATED PRINCIPLES
THAT. ALLOWED US TO TAKE. GOOD
CARE OF OUR STAFF THROUGH THIS
CRISIS WE RECOGNIZED IN ABOUT
THE THIRD WEEK OF MARCH THAT WE
WERE. ENTERING INTO AND WOULD
BE EXPERIENCING A SUSTAINED
TRAUMA FOR AN UNKNOWN PERIOD OF
TIME ONE OF THE TENETS OF BEING
A TRAUMA INFORMED SYSTEM IS
TRANSPARENCY COMMUNICATION-
AND- THE ABILITY TO REALLY HEAR
WHAT OUR STAFF HAD TO SAY- I'VE
SO I'VE- EARLY DAYS MARCH WE
STARTED IMPLEMENTING DAILY WEB
AXES WE HAD DISCIPLINE SPECIFIC
WEB ACCESS. TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE BI DIRECTIONAL
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR STAFF WE
DID THEM ACROSS ALL SHIFTS.
INCLUDING ARE NOT SHIFT- WHERE
WE WOULD PUSH OUT THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE BUT WE
ALSO GATHERED INFORMATION SO WE
DEVELOPED A PROCESS WHEREBY.
ANY AND ALL STAFF QUESTIONS
WERE COLLECTED DURING THOSE
WEBACCESS WE WOULD BRING THOSE
QUESTIONS TO THE EXACTLY. IF
TEAM AN EXECUTIVE TEAM MADE A
COMMITMENT. TO OUR STAFF TO
HAVE ANSWERS BACK OUT- WITHIN I
THINK FORTY EIGHT HOURS SO IF
SOMEONE HAD A QUESTION ABOUT
WHY THEY WERE GIVEN A SURGICAL
MASK INSTEAD OF AN N. NINETY
FIVE OR HOW TO CLEAN THAT OR-
YOU KNOW WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE. ARE WE COULD PUSH OUT
ANSWERS TO THEM IN REAL TIME
AND ALSO HEAR THEIR SUGGESTIONS
AND CONCERNS AND TRY TO
INCORPORATE THAT SO I THINK THE
PRINCIPLE OF TRANSPARENCY-
THROUGH- VERY ACTIVE
COMMUNICATION BI DIRECTIONALLY-
IT WAS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT- ASPECTS OF WHAT WE
DID. I WE HAD A SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE CONSTANTLY COMING THE
LITERATURE AND THE GUIDANCE TO
MAKE SURE THAT- YOU KNOW OUR
STAFF ARE SMART THEY'RE MENTAL
HEALTH CLINICIANS SO WE
DEVELOPED A WEBSITE- WITH ALL
CURRENT INFORMATION SO THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MORE COMPLEX OR
SOPHISTICATED QUESTIONS WOULD
HAVE. ALL THE CURRENT RESOURCES
THAT WE KNEW OF AT THEIR
FINGERTIPS TO DO. KIND OF
RESEARCH- AND IT'S BEEN YOU
KNOW HOW DO YOU SUPPORT YOUR
STAFF IN A IN A WAR I MEAN
WE'VE BEEN AT WAR WITH THIS-
VIRUS AS CLINICIANS- FOR THE
LAST YEAR- SO JUST TRYING TO BE
KIND. OF MAKE SURE WE LISTEN
AND MAKE SURE WE RESPOND TO
STAFF- CONCERNS AS A AS A
CULTURE. RIGHT NOW WE'RE
ENTERING INTO A PHASE AND WE
HAVE BEEN CONSULTING WITH OUR
OUR NATIONAL CENTER FOR TRAUMA
INFORMED KERR OF- PERHAPS
HOPEFULLY- THE WORST IS BEHIND
US. I AS THE VACCINES ROLL OUT
BUT WE NEED TO GRIEVE NOW WE
NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE TRAUMA
THAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THROUGH
SO WE HAVE A PLAN FOR THAT-
INCLUDING- STARTING YESTERDAY
WE HAD A STATE WIDE MOMENT OF
SILENCE FOR. THOSE THAT WE'VE
LOST. AND I WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON A HEALING QUILT WITH
HER REHABILITATION THERAPISTS
WERE PATIENTS AND STAFF CAN
CONTRIBUTE A VIRTUAL SQUARE- TO
THE QUILT. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO BE SO OPEN WHETHER IS
WITH CHECK- COUNSELING SERVICE.
AND WE'RE PUSH OUT READ IS
REALLY TO AGREE COUNTRY TO
WORKING INTO OUR- OUR-
TREATMENT GROUPS- IN THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YEAH YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
RIGHT WE'VE WE'VE BEEN AT WAR-
AND I BEFORE WE MOVE ON I I'LL
I'LL JUST SAY TO IF I CAN IF I
CAN HELP IN ANY KIND OF WAY IF
YOU WANT A COUPLE WORDS FROM
THAT BUDGET SUB THREE PERSON AT
THE VIRTUAL EVENT. I'M GLAD TO
GLAD TO LEND A VOICE HEARD
ANYTHING FROM THE PARTNER
FINANCE ON THIS. HELLO. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALRIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON TO OURNEXT ISSUE
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. LESS I LOST
MY WAY. YOUR RUN ISSUE NUMBER
THREE OKAY WE'RE ON THE SAME
PAGE JUST SO GREAT OKAY AND
I'LL BE UP REALLY THIS IS JUST
ASKING FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET YOUR EYES
PROVIDE FUNDING PARKING
RESPONSE TO KEVIN KNIGHT
INCREASE THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
ONE QUESTIONS FOR LEVINE SAYS
IT IS ONE OF THE TOP HEALTH AND-
THIS REALLY IS JUST THE- ALL OF
THE- WE JUST. GOT THIS INCLUDES
TEN MILLION PER PERSON SERVICE
THIRTY FIVE NINE NINE ON OUR
OPERATING AND BY MOUNTAIN SEVEN
NINE FOR ONGOING TAX- I'LL KEEP
THAT ONE BRIEF. LAST YEAR HOW
MUCH. NO I DON'T THINK SO-
THANK. NAY ANIMAL. SIMILAR
DISEASE HERE TO QUESTION THE
THIS I AM NOT FOR ANYTHING YOU
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ANYTHING APART FINANCE. A
LAWYER. YOU CAN JUST IT OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
TO LET'S GO. LET'S MOVE ON WE
CAN ISSUE NUMBER. YOU THINK
YEAH I AM BLIND TO READ THIS I
INFORMED BY THE DEPUTY. CHRIS
SO I'M GONNA COVER THE FOR.
APPLEBEE'S IS NOT UP BATES AND
THEN SHE WERE TAKE FULL. I
DON'T RELATED TO THE- REALLY
PROGRAM THE JOB OFF A- THREE
PROGRAM I'M FOR THE END. OKAY
SO THE FIRST ITEM WITH THIS. IS
THE LAND FROM PARTRIDGE I AND
SIR INTO. THIS IS YOUR I JUST
THINK RAN. ALREADY AT EIGHT
POINT ONE MILLION. IN ANNUAL WE
AN UPDATE ON THE AMOUNT OF RAM.
WE ANSWERED CLASS FROM RELAY TO
THE OF. WHO ARE CONSERVE
COMMITTED DEPART OF ENVIRONMENT
SHORT. REQUEST WE ARE
ANTICIPATING A SAVINGS OF
EIGHTEEN POINT SIX MILLION NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY. APPOINT
EXPOSITIONS RELATED TO THIS
ACTIVITY. IN PREVIOUS YEARS WE
WERE READING FUNDING TO CONVERT
EXISTING BACK ASKEY. D. S. H.
METROPOLITAN AND THIS WAS
PROVIDE SECURE FORENSIC FACT
POSSIBLY BY ADDING A REQUIRED
SECURITY FENCING AND RESPECT
AROUND AN EXISTING BUILDING AS
PROVIDE MORE A SECURE BANK I
SEE FOR THE TREATMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS FOUND INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL. AND THIS WAS
GOING TO PROVIDE FIVE
ADDITIONAL TREATMENT UNITS I
TOTALING TWO HUNDRED NINETY SIX
ADDS UP. FOR THE IC THREE. AND
TWENTY NINETEEN WE DID COMPLETE
FROM. OF THEM CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT AND SUBSEQUENTLY WORK
ACTIVATING UNITS AS THEY WERE
COMPLETED I WE ACTIVATED ONE IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN THE
OTHER IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND THEN. THAT AND SO
THE THIRD UNIT THAT WAS
SCHEDULED TO MEET MARCH
ALTERNATELY WAS PLACED ON HOLD
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC. AND ALL
THREE OF THE REMAINING UNITS
ARE NOW ALTERNATELY BEING
UTILIZED AND A NIGHT IN
RESPONSE AND WE TALKED ABOUT WE
NEEDED TO ESTABLISH ISOLATION
AND BEYOND QUARANTINE UNITS AND
MISSION OBSERVATION ARE OUR
HOSPITAL SAID. THE SPACE RENTS
AND THESE LAST THREE UNITS ARE
CURRENTLY BEING UTILIZED OR
NOT- IRAN WE ARE HOPING AS SOON
AS- THINGS RETURN TO NORMALCY
WILL BE ABLE TO BRING THOSE.
UNITS BACK ONLINE ASK. FOR ICE
TEA TREATMENT NEXT YEAR. AT THE
END HE- PROGRAM. WE HAD. A ONE
TIME SAVING UP POINT SEVEN NINE
IN THIRTY POINT HIS.THIS AND
HERE AND ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION ELEVEN POINT SIX
POSITIONS IN BUDGET. BEYONCE IS
GONNA BE SIMILAR THEME I WORK
WITH OKAY. IN PRIOR YEARS WE
WERE AUTHORIZED TO CONSTRUCT
AND OPERATE THE ENHANCE
TREATMENT PROGRAM. IN THE ETP
IS A NEW ENHANCED LEVEL OF CARE
OF THAT'S DESIGNED TO TREAT
PATIENTS WHO ARE AT THE HIGHEST
RISK OF VIOLENCE AND WHO'S NOT
BE SAFELY TREATED IN THE
STANDARD. BY ENVIRONMENT. ARE
THEREFORE UNITS THEIR PLAN
THREE TO TASK FOR THEIR- AND
ONE AT THE STATE HOSPITAL. IN
PRIOR TO THE NINETEEN WE HAD
BECOME THE CONSTRUCTION ON ON
THE FIRST UNITS ASPIRO AND
OPINIONS. NEED INSTRUCTION ON
THE OTHER UNITS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR WITH HOSPIRA. AND APART
AND WE CAN JUST STARTED THE
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITY ONE
FOLLOWED BEYOND OF FOR THE ONE
UNIT THERE AND ULTIMATELY ON
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THIS GROUP
THAT THESE REMAINING THREE
UNITS TO EDITAS GIRL AND ONE
OUT TOTTON WERE PLACED ON HOLD
UNLESS THOSE. UNITS WERE NEEDED
FOR PANDEMIC RESPONSE. ON THE
FIRST UNIT ATASCADERO IS NEAR
COMPLETION AND WE ARE
FINALIZING. PLANS ACTIVATE THAT.
WE WENT THEN THAT- THE END THE
END OF THE YEAR I REALLY
DEPENDING HOW GO. THAT BURKE
AND- SERVICES INPATIENT WAITING
FACE. OUT OF THIS IS A YEAR
UPDATE YOUR- SAVINGS OF APPROX
HOW AS- ALL RELATED TO THE CASE
SERVICE AND THEN. WAY AND THIS
REALLY IS DO TO. NINETEEN KIANA-
THAT THE KEY READ. I REALLY
WERE AND- DUE TO RESPECT ON
CASE WORKING MOVEMENT THE
FACILITY TO LIMIT ON THE- SOUND.
IN FACT THROUGHOUT THE HOUSE.
NOT A MISSION BASED REVIEW
STAFF STUDY OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WE HAD
PRESENTED SEVERAL STOPPING
STUDIES RELATED TO DIRECTOR
NURSING BOARD EVALUATIONS
REPORTS TREATMENT TEAM PRIMARY
CARE IN LINES ARE PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. FOR THE DIRECT CARE
NURSING- THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY NINE EIGHTEEN APPROVED
IT'S NOT THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE IVE POSITIONS AND
FORTY SIX NOT FORTY SIX
MILLION- THEY WERE ORIGINALLY
TO BE PHASED IN OVER A THREE
YEAR LAST YEAR NAY REVISION DUE
TO AN ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES
AROUND AT THE NINETEEN STRETCH
THAT OUT TO BE PHASED IN OVER
FOUR YEAR PERIOD- AND THESE
POSITIONS PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
AND PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS
NEED DIRECT PATIENT CARE NEEDS
AND PROVIDE AS SUPERVISING
REGISTERED NURSES TO. INCREASE.
OUR PROBLEMS NURSING
SUPERVISION. AND AT NIGHT
TWENTY ROOM SPEED THIRTY THREE
POINT EIGHT POSITIONS ON HOW
FELT ALL THIRTY POINT EIGHT
SPECIAL. IN THE CURRENT. WE'VE
BEEN ON. AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT
WORK- AND- IT'S ME AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY ACTIVELY WORKING TO
FILL THESE POSITIONS AND THEN
BUDGET YEAR WE'RE ALREADY
AUTHORIZED IT'S NOT A NEW ASKED
BUT WE WILL BE WORKING TERRIBLY
JUST NINE NINETY FIVE POINT
EIGHT. I'M NETWORK IS THE FIRST.
SIMILARLY BURKE FORTY NINE
NATIONS REPORTS WE WERE NINETY
FOUR POINT SIX POSITIONS AND
FORTY POINT TWO MILLION IN
TWENTY NINETEEN I'M NOT ARE
PLANNED TO BE PHASED IN OVER
FOUR YEARS AND THERE WERE
POSITIONS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CLINICIAN RESOURCES FOR
VALUATIONS AND COURT RECORDS
AND TESTIMONY CASE MANAGEMENT
AND DATA TRACKING AND OUR
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSESSMENTS AND
TREATMENT AND WORK. IN OUR
MEDIATION PILOT PROGRAM WE ARE
PROGRESSING IN HIRING THESE
POSITIONS AS WELL AND THE
BUDGET WILL BE WORKING TO FILL
AN ADDITIONAL NINETEEN GREAT
SEX. POSITIONS UP FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES. AND THEN A LAST OR
WE CAN DO TO STOPPING STUDIES
THE TREATMENT TEAM OF PRIMARY
CARE SERVICES AND PROTECTED
START PROTECTIVE SERVICES AS
THOSE WERE PRESENTED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET- BUT DUE TO THE
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES AROUND
HAVING NINETEEN WERE NOT FULLY
FUNDED RECEIVE PARTIAL APPROVAL
FOR TOTAL FOR BOTH OF THESE
VISIT. OUR OUR PROPOSALS A FIVE
MILLION IN PUBLIC FIVE
POSITIONS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
AND TEN MILLION AND THIRTY
POSITIONS IN THE BUDGET YOU'RE
ON ON GOING. ON WITH THIS I
REDUCE FUNDING AND RESOURCES WE
DID PRIORITIZE IMPLEMENTATION
OUR- RESOURCES OUT OF THOSE.
BUDGET AS PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
OUR CLINICAL EXECUTIVE TEAM
THAT- THE PLANTATION IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT- PRIMARY
MEDICAL CARE RESOURCES THAT
WERE CONTAINED IN THE TREATMENT
IN THE PRIMARY. CARE STAFFING.
THAT'S PART OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST WE ARE REQUESTING TEN
ARM IT WAS A- MCCARTY ONLY TO
PROVIDE. YOU OUR HOUSE. BACKED
UP FOR QUITE A IT IS A THAT HAD
BEEN REDUCED TO OUR- OP.
ADVISORY COUNCIL IN OUR INBOX.
DIVISION OF SACRAMENTO. AND FOR
THE PROTECTIVE SIR COMPONENT
MARIE. TO PERMANENT. ON THIS
AGAIN A STORY ONLY- SUBSEQUENT
TO THIS FISCAL YEAR SUBJECT TO
THAT REDUCE APPROVAL AND
FUNDING RIGHT I'M FOR THE
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND
TREATMENT TEAM. AT STOPPING
STUDIES WE DID WORK WITH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO
ADMINISTRATIVELY ESTABLISHED
BOB HOSPITAL POLICE OFFICER
POSITION IN UTILIZED FUNDING-
OVER IN THE UTILIZED OVER TIME
FINDING. A FAR OFF BROWN'S
CASSIDY TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL.
RESOURCES TO FACILITATE OFF
GROUND I SEE SERVICES REDUCED
THAT RELIANCE ON AVERAGE I'M
SORRY QUESTION ONGOING
POSITION. ONLY INVOLVED. I OVER
HOURS. IN ADDITION TO THE STAFF
STUDIES ALSO WORKFORCE PROPOSAL
AND PRIOR THE FORTY OUT OF
THESE A SECOND STUDY AS
PROPOSALS IN THESE IN NURSE
INSTRUCTOR POSITION FOR YOUNGER
SINGER AND TRAINING ACT. I
RESOURCES DEVELOP A FIVE THANK
YOU RESIDENTS PROGRAM AT THE
APARTMENTS HOSPITALS NAPA. OKAY
NINETEEN DELAYED SOME OF THE
LIKE TRAINING EFFORTS- DSE
HOSPITAL AND INTER PARTNERSHIP
WITH BEST COLLEGE THE BEEN IN
BY THE BOARD OF. NURSING LIKE
AFTER TECHNICIANS AREN'T
INCREASE OUR CLASS SIZE FROM
THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE. AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT EXPANDED
CLASSIFIES TO BE OPENED IN MAY
OF THIS YEAR FOR NOW BUT IN
COALINGA WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE MYSELF
ALEX ON THOSE EXPANSION EFFORTS
AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
ANTICIPATING SAVINGS ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND IN
FRONT YARD IN THE DELAYS. ARE
COMMERCE INSTRUCTORS AND SIGNED
ONES ARE INCREASING THAT THAT.
SAYS. LAST NIGHT. AS FOR THE
LIKE WHAT READ PRO WITH
COMPLETE AMOUNTS AFFILIATION
AGREE WITH STATE JOSEPH. CENTER
TO A NEW. PROGRAM WE ME SO. I
THANK PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR NOW
BECAUSE I'M THAT WAY THAT WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE PROBE DIRECTOR.
SEIZURES MEDIC CENTER. ARE AND
TO ECJ. HANDS LIKE THIS IT WAS
NOT GOOD WITH ACGME- BACK IN
OCTOBER AND WE'RE JUST WAITING
FOR. IT TO DETECT IF I GOT TO.
THE OUR CREDIT AND IF THE
PRESIDENT WE DOING. THAT READ
PROGRAMS IN JULY- IT'S NOT IN.
IT DOES START JULY WE ARE
EXPECTING OUR FOR RESIDENTS I'M
FROM THE ESTATE FOR FREE FROM
SAINT JOSEPH BIRDS BUT ONE
SEVEN- RESIDENTS AND BY THE
FOURTH YEAR RESIDENCY WITH. AND
THEN FINALLY FOR ME I TELL
PSYCHIATRY RESOURCE IS A ONE
TIME SAVINGS- BURKE. IS
SPENDING MORE TIME SAVINGS OF
NINE HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND
SIX POINT FIVE POSITIONS
RELATED TO HEALTH I RESOURCES
APPROVED IN A TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET AT. OF THE BUDGET ACT
AUTHORIZED EIGHTEEN DECISIONS
FOR TELETECH. I THANK THE
PERMISSION AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT TO BE FILLED
OVER TWO YEARS OUT NOW CALLING
ON FEDERAL. AND THIS WAS
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO ALLOW. THE
DEPARTMENT TO EXPAND ITS USE OF
TELE PSYCHIATRY CAN HELP FILL
INSISTING BAKER STOPS LIKE I
DISPOSITIONS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ARE THESE POSITIONS IN
NINETEEN TWENTY WE FELT. LIKE
FIVE OF THE POSITIONS THAT
AFGHAN CALLING GOT AND WORKING
TO FILL THE REMAINING POSITIONS
MCCARTY- AND PLAN TO
REDISTRIBUTE- SEVEN POSITIONS
FROM ATASCADERO T<c.cyan> CG</c>
GUY. I'M SOMEONE TURN OVER NOW
TO PRESS ON EVEN TERMS TO TALK
ABOUT DARK ON REFUSE LET
ATHLETES IN. JOHN BASS
CONFIDENT THE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WELCOME AT THE DIRECTORY.
ZERO SO MUCH. I'M SO I'M GOING
TO CUT THE KEY AT EATS THE CAR
PROBE- THE FIRST ITEM IN THE
CONRAD NON SVP CASELOAD AND
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR- DSHS
REQUESTING ONE POINT TWO
MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR IN
ONGOING TO SUPPORT THE
OPERATIONAL COST INCREASES
THROUGH ARE CONTRACTED ON
RECORD FIGHTERS- AS PART OF THE
BUDGETING AND CONTRACT
NEGOTIATION PROCESS CONVERT
PROVIDERS IDENTIFY- THOSE
INCREASES TO THEIR OPERATIONAL
COSTS- AND OUR CONTRACT COUNTY
PROVIDERS ARE OBLIGATED REALLY
TO PROVIDE- SALARY INCREASES
IMPOSED BY THEIR RESPECTIVE-
COLLECTED AT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING CONTRACTS. INSIDIOUS
AGES REALLY REQUESTING FUNDING
TO SUPPORT BOTH THE SALARY AN
OPERATING EXPENSE INCREASES FOR
OUR CONTRACTED PROVIDERS TO
AVOID- OUR CONTRACTORS
EXPERIENCING A FUNDING
SHORTFALL AND IN ORDER TO MEET
THEIR CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS
WITH OPERATING OUR PROGRAMS AND
THE IMPACT OF THE INSUFFICIENT
FUNDING TO SUPPORT- OUR
STAFFING ARE REQUIRED STAFFING
LEVELS COULD RESULT IN AB ONE
REDUCTION- THE STAFF AT CELLS
AND TRANSLATE DIRECTLY TO A
REDUCTION IN THE KEYS SO THAT
THEY CAN. WORK THE NEXT I IS
REALLY JUST A CASELOAD DAY
WE'RE REQUESTING AND- IN THIS
IS TO THE CON SB PP SLOWED-
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR AN ADDRESS
WE CONTINUE TO ASSUME A
CASELOAD OF TWENTY ONE-
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PROGRAM
AND THEN WILL UPDATE OUR
PROJECTION. AFTER PRESENTATION
OF PETITIONS. THE NEXT ITEM IS
ALSO ARE CONDITIONAL RELEASE
PROGRAM ARE CONTINUING OF CARE-
STEP DOWN TRANSITIONAL PROGRAM.
IN THE CURRENT YEAR YES EACH IS
ESTIMATING ONE TIME SAVINGS OF
NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION. DUE
TO THE DELAY IN THE ACTIVATION
OF ARMY'S SEVENTY EIGHT BACK I
AM DEPROGRAMMING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THIS WILL BE A STEP
DOWN PROGRAM FOR STATE HOSPITAL
PATIENTS THAT ARE APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
OUT FROM BEING CONNED REFEREE.
AS A RESULT OF CONSTRUCTION
DELAYS AND YOUTUBE PANDEMIC
ACTIVATION IS NOW EXPECTED TO
OCCUR IN APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WHERE ARE REGIONAL AND
TIMELINE FOR THIS PROJECT AS
SOON APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
ACTIVATION. IN THE BUDGET YEAR-
WE'RE ALSO REQUESTING AN
EXPANSION OF ON THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE REQUESTING SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION AND- HALF OF THE
POSITION TO SUPPORT PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION AN ACTIVATION.
CHIU NEW PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR-
WITHIN OUR CONRAD. THE FIRST IS
A STEP DOWN PROGRAM IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE PROVIDER
THAT DíAS SPEECHES RECENTLY
CONTRACTED WITH. TEN BEDS- AND
THIS WILL SUPPORT THE NOT
GUILTY BY REASON OF INSANITY
POPULATION- DUE TO THE DELAY
WITH OUR SEVENTY EIGHT THAT
PROGRAM WE WERE ABLE TO UTILIZE
CURRENT YOUR SAVINGS- TO
CONTRACT THIS PROVIDER ON THE
PROVIDER HAS ALSO EXPRESSED AN
INTEREST IN EXPANDING BY AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY. AREN'T
BUYING EXCUSE ME BRING
ADDITIONAL TEN BEDS- SO WE ARE
REQUESTING THREE POINT SIX
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE TOTAL
COST OF ALL TWENTY NINE ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. IN A- WE'VE ALSO
IDENTIFIED AND ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH EIGHT TWENTY BACK-
MENTAL HEALTH REHAB CENTER
PROGRAM THAT IS DESIGNED TO
SERVE THE I. S. T. POPULATION.
A STUDIO STAGE IS CURRENTLY IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THIS PROGRAM.
AND WE HOPE ON THAT BY NEXT
YEAR THAT WE CAN SERVE I ISSUES
IN THIS PROGRAM THOSE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY ORDERED OUT TO
CONDITIONAL RELEASE. THE NEXT
ITEM. MINE IS AN UPDATE TO OUR
JAIL BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAMS FOR EXISTING GB CG
PROGRAMS WE GET- ANTICIPATE ONE
TIME CURRENT YOUR SAVINGS A
TRIBUTE TO THE DELAYED
ACTIVATION TO PROGRAMS THE
FIRST IS THREE POINT TWO
MILLION IN SAVINGS FROM A PLAN
TO THIRTY BAD ACTIVATION I- FOR
EXPANSION EXCUSE ME AT THE
CURRENT MISSION EVALUATION
STABILIZATION CENTER. ON THE
DELAY IS REALLY DUE TO THE NEED
FOR THE SHERIFF TO RESERVE
SPACE FOR KOBE QUARANTINE THAT.
AT THE A NUMBER OF IDENTITIES
ACROSS THE HAVE RICH A LITTLE
YEAR WHICH IS IMPACT THE
FILLING OF NEW POSITIONS UNTIL
MU. NEW RECRUITS. A COMPLETE
CAL TRAINING. CURRENT WE'RE
ANTICIPATING TERAKHIR IN JULY
TWENTY ONE. IN ADDITION- WE ARE
ESTIMATING SAVINGS- NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND IN
THE CURRENT YEAR RELATED TO THE
DELAYED ACTIVATION APARTMENT
TEN THAT PROGRAM IN CALAVERAS
COUNTY. ON THIS PROGRAM WAS
INITIALLY ESTIMATED TO ACTIVATE
AND BEGIN PATIENT ADMISSIONS IN
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY HOWEVER
DUE TO DELAYS IN FINALIZING THE
CONTRACTING GETTING START UP
ACTIVITIES UNDER WAY WE'RE NOW
ANTICIPATING. ASIAN NATIONS TO
BEGIN NEXT MONTH. IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND ON GOING WE ARE ALSO
REQUESTING SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
CONTRACT ALL ORDERS TO SUPPORT
INCREASED COSTS- FOUR GB CG
TREATMENT PROVIDER IN THE
WORDS. I TO EMPLOY A MOBILE
PSYCHOLOGISTS TO SUPPORT
SEVERAL OF OUR WORLD LEAD
LOCATED NORTHERN CALIFORNIA G.
BCG'S ARE EXPERIENCING OUR
RECRUITMENT CHALLENGES AND SO
THIS PSYCHOLOGIST WILL ACTUALLY
TRAVEL BETWEEN VARIOUS
LOCATIONS TO PROVIDE AN ON SITE
PRESENCE. OUT WHILE ALSO USING
TELEHEALTH TO SUPPLEMENT
SERVICE DELIVERY SO REALLY WHAT
THIS FUNDS ARE FOR IS REALLY
JUST TO SUPPORT THAT-
INCREASING TRAVEL COSTS IN THE
BETWEEN. THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
MISTER CAN YOU SEE WHERE THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA J. B. C. A.
B. C. T. SITES. SURE YEAH- SO
SHASTA. HUMBOLDT. WE ALSO DO
HAVE A PROGRAM IN YEARS BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT THE TRAVELING
PSYCHOLOGISTS WILL SUPPORT THAT
PROGRAM WE ALSO HAVE PROGRAMS
IN MENDOCINO. AND- AS I
MENTIONED ALSO CALAVERAS COUNTY.
IT WE ALSO HAVE ONE IN PLASTER
SACRAMENTO. OKAY. WITH ONE TO
THE NEXT ITEM ON AND THAT IS
ALSO JAIL BASED COMPETENCY
TREATMENT PROGRAMS- THIS IS AN
INCREASE- REQUEST FOR NEW
PROGRAMS WERE REQUESTING SIX
POINT THREE MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AN ON GOING ON TO
SUPPORT THE ACTIVATION OF
THIRTY ONE NEW GBC CHEAP THAT'S
ACROSS SEVENTY COUNTY PROGRAMS-
WE ACTUALLY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ACCELERATE THE OPENING OF
OUR NEW EIGHT AT PROGRAM IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
ACTIVATED IN DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ANSWER TO SUPPORT THESE
COSTS IN THE CURRENT YEAR WE'RE
REQUESTING TO SHIP. THEM ABOUT
ONE TIME SAVINGS FROM THE
DELAYED ACTIVATION OF THE
CURRENT EIGHT YES- FINANCIAL.
SEVEN SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND. ALSO INCLUDED IN
THIS REQUEST IS TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND TO SUPPORT- CONTRACTED
PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCACY
SERVICE SENSE- WHICH IS SORT OF
THE STANDARD ADJUSTMENT THAT
WOULD INCLUDE WITH ALL ARGUED
REQUESTED PROGRAMS. THE END OF
MY PRESENTATION ON THE CASE.
CAN YOU ED ARE IS THAT THERE'S
A STANDARDIZED METHODOLOGY OF
CARE AT EACH OF THESE SITES AND
IS SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU WERE
DOING. IN THE FACILITIES BEFORE
YOU TOOK THEM OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY. ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
THE GBC YES YES FOR ME THE
CONDITIONAL RELEASE. C. T.
SITES- WELL WRITTEN WITH
RESPECT TO THE TREATMENT THE
TREATMENT IS VERY CONSISTENT TO
WHAT IS OFFERED- IN THE STATE
HOSPITALS BECAUSE IT IS IN A
LOCKED CAN CHANGE ENVIRONMENT
AND SO- THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE
STAFFED WITH PSYCHOLOGISTS-
PRIMARILY AS WELL AS SOCIAL
WORK- TO DELIVER GROUP FACE
TREATMENT AND EVALUATION
SERVICES BUT I GUESS WITH
RESPECT TO CO BAD ON THERE
THERE DEFINITELY WERE SOME
OPERATIONAL CHANGES MADE-
PRIMARILY DUE TO REDUCING GROUP
SIZE OR IN SOME CASES-
ELIMINATING GROUP AND GOING
MORE TO A ONE TO ONE-
INDIVIDUALIZED TREATMENT
PROGRAM. I THINK DUE TO THE
SIZE AND- SORT OF SCOPE OF MOST
OF THE PROGRAMS MAJORITY OF THE
PROGRAM'S NOW HOW ARE FIVE FIVE
TO TEN DAY PROGRAMS IT'S EASIER
TO DELIVER THE INDIVIDUAL BASED
TREATMENT- BUT AS A AS- SORT OF
THE RISK OF CODE VEIN- AND AS
FOLKS HAVE BEEN GETTING-
VACCINATED THOSE GROUPS- HAVE
DEFINITELY OPENED BACK UP AT
ARMS ON MORE OF THE SMALLER
SCALE OKAY AND HAVE YOU SEEN
ISSUES- OR DO YOU ANTICIPATE
ISSUES WITH RECRUITMENT AND
STAFFING AS AS WE'VE SEEN AN
EDUCATIONAL OF TEACHER JUST
RETIRING I'M ASSUMING YOU'VE
HAD A LOT OF. STAFF WHO WERE
YOU KNOW NEARING RETIREMENT AGE
OF JUST GONNA HAD RETIRED AND
THEN. DO YOU ANTICIPATE THERE'S
GOING TO BE. ALBUM WITH
RECRUITMENT RETENTION GOING.
WELL THESE THESE ARE ARE- ARE
DEPARTMENTS CONTRA PROBE- WE DO
THE WAY THESE ARE WE DIRECTLY
WITH THE SHERIFF AND THE
SHERIFF AND SUBCONTRACTS WITH
MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND- BY AND
LARGE- IT IS PARTICULARLY IN
URBAN AREAS WE DON'T HAVE AS
MUCH- RECRUITMENT. CERTAINLY WE
HAVE SEEN NOT IN OUR MORE AS
THEY DESCRIBED AND MORE RURAL
AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES WHICH IS WHY WE WERE
TRYING TO THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX
AND- GO WITH- MORE ABOUT
MOBILE- MODEL OF CARE AS WELL
AS- SUPPLEMENTING WITH WHICH
AND TELEHEALTH- AND SO I THINK.
BY HAVING THOSE RESOURCES IT'LL
DEFINITELY HELP TO OPEN UP
THERE THE DOOR- TO EASE WITH
THAT RECRUITING CHALLENGES BUT
IN TERMS OF LIKE RETIREMENTS I
DON'T FORESEE IT BEING ANY MORE
DIFFICULT THAN IT HAS BEEN- IN-THE RECENT YEARS BUT WE'RE
PRETTY STRATEGIC ABOUT- ARE
PLANNING WHEN WE DO OPEN UP THE
STREET THE CITY PROGRAM'S
REALLY WORKING WITH THE
SHERIFF'S AND TRYING TO TIME-
TRYING TO TIME THE OPENING THE
PROGRAMS TO WIN RECRUITMENT AND
SUCCESSFUL CRITIC IS TAKING
PLACE. SO PRETTY MINDFUL- STATS.
OKAY AND IN ANYTHING ADD ON
THAT JUST IN THE LARGER SYSTEM
CONCERNS ABOUT STAFFING
RECRUITING GOING FORWARD STAFF
HEALTH. BUT YOU KNOW THE AS A
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE A WHOLE BIT
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OR
POSSIBLY HM WE DEFINITELY HAVE
SOME CLASSIFICATIONS THAT
ALREADY WORDS PARENTING
CHALLENGES BECAUSE OF BAD. ARE
WITH RESPECT TO RECRUITMENT SO
IT'S ALWAYS AN ONGOING EFFORT
IN WORK I TEACH RIGHTS WHO
REALLY RECRUITS- E.ON RETAIN
THE STOP THAT WE HAVE THAT'S
WHY WE ALSO ARE WORKING HERE
KIND OF- SOME OF THE THINGS WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT TRYING TO
STOP HIS ARMS. HAS LIKE IT
RESIDENCY PROGRAM AND TO
INCREASE WORK WITH THE- WITH
OUR EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS TO
KIND OF INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE TRAINING
FOR AN APARTMENT SESSIONS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GROW ON YOUR
OWN AND YOU DON'T AND YOU TRAIN
THEM WITHIN YOUR SYSTEM OFTEN
THEY STAY WITHIN THEIR SYSTEM
SO THAT'S WHY. WE STARTED
WORKING. ON SOME OF THE
STRATEGIES AS WELL. OKAY THANK
YOU ANYTHING FROM THE PARK
FINANCE. HELLO OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- WE DID
GET EVERY DETAIL RIGHT UP AS
WELL- IN OUR PACKETS SO- I
GUESS BUT THE LARGER QUESTION
IS- SO GIVEN CASELOAD SO ALL
THE DIFFERENT CHANGES YOU
YOU'VE YOU'VE PATIENTLY HERE
EXPLAINED TO US- WHAT IS THE
NET CHANGE IN THE BUDGET
REQUEST AS A RESULT OF THE-
CASELOAD UPDATES. THE FINAL
BOTTOM LINE. OUR OUR TOTAL
BUDGET INCREASES OF THREE
HUNDRED NINETY. THREE MILLION
THAT VOTED FOR A CASE LIKE
CHANGES ALONE- YES I WOULD DO I
KNOW WHAT IS THE CHANGE IN THE
BUDGET RELATED CASELOADS AS WAS
PRESENTED HERE SO WE HAVE YOU
KNOW SOME DISPENSES GOING UP
SOME EXPENSES GOING DOWN THE
FOR TO CETERA WHICH WE WENT
THROUGH IN GREAT DETAIL BUT-
WHAT WAS THE BOTTOM LINE. I
WILL GIVE ME A MOMENT AND I
WILL GET BACK TO YOU CAN GET
BACK TO ME ON THAT ONE OKAY-
YEAH SO THAT'S THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL I JUST JUST MAKE. JUST
MAKE NOTE HERE AND BUDGETS OF
THREE BECAUSE ONE OF THE ITEMS
HERE IS A DHS S. H. IS
REQUESTING A GENERAL FUND
EXPENSES THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AND JUST A WEEK AGO WE
WERE TALKING A HUNDRED TWENTY
BILLION. SO JUST- YOU KNOW FOR
A MEDIC CAL AND CHANGE AND
PROGRAMS UPSWING IN MORE THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS EACH WAY EACH
YEAR SO JUST A SERVE A CONTRAST
AS TO WHAT WE HEAR HERE FROM
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO.
BILLIONS SO- OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU OKAY AND I
THINK CENTER MELINDA'S HAS THAT
FROM HAD TO HAD TO HAD TO GO
OKAY SHALL WE MOVE ON. WOULD BE
NEAT. AGAIN CHRISTINE N. B.DIRECTOR FOR THE FORENSIC
SERVICES DIVISION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
AND WAR YES I AM I AM JOINED BY
OUR MEDICAL DIRECTOR DR KEEP
WARBURTON. AND THIS IS FIVE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
DIVERSION PROGRAM EXPANSION AND
RECREATION. IN SURVEY- FOR THIS
THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING
ONE TIME FUNDING OF FORTY SIX
POINT FORTY SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION TO EXPAND THE CURRENT
I. S. T. DIVERSION PROGRAM TO
BOTH CURRENT AND NEW CHANNELS.
THIS REQUEST INCLUDES FORTY SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION IN FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THE COUNTY OPERATED
PROGRAMS AND ONE POINT TWO
MILLION TO MANAGE THE ROLL OUT
OF NEW FRIENDS AND SUPPORT THE
OPERATION OF THIS PROGRAM THREE
FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX- AND SO WITH THIS NEW.
FINDING REQUEST WE ACTUALLY
WOULD BOB THOSE TWO- EXPAND
THIS PROGRAM TO BE THIRTY THREE
ADDITIONAL COUNTIES THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY NOT PARTNERING THAT-
THE OPERATIONAL SPENDING
REQUESTED ONE POINT TWO MILLION
IS A FOUR FIVE YEAR LIMITED
TERMS WORDS. ON AND IT IS
COMPRISED IS COMPRISED OF
THREE- TRANSITIONS ARE
APPROXIMATELY HALF A MILLION
YOU WILL NEED FOR OUR RESEARCH
CONTRACT WITH YOU SEE DAVIS
WHICH SUPPORTS REQUIRED DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING
EFFORTS INCLUDING TRACKING WITH
IT IS SOMETIMES A DIVERSION
PARTICIPANTS. AND LASTLY OUR
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND ANNUALLY
TO CONTRACT WITH NATIONAL
EXPERTS TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AREN'T YOU
WEREN'T COUNTIES ON BEST
PRACTICES AND TREATMENT
MODALITIES FOR THIS POPULATION-
EXPANDING DIVERSION PROGRAMS IS
REALLY ONE OF THE FEW AVAILABLE
PASSED. THAT WE HERE AT DS EACH
HAVE TO CREATE A CITY PRICE
TEENS- IN ADDITION THE PROGRAM
ALLOWS CHINESE TO DIVERT
DEFENDANTS BEFORE BEING
DECLARED AS AN I. S. T. R.
SABRINA HELP REDUCE THE OVERALL
NUMBER. OF SELLING ICE TEAS IN
THE STATE. MANY OF OUR EXISTING
COUNTY PROGRAMS THAT WE WORK
WITH I HAVE EXPRESSED
INTERESTING IN EXPANDING THEIR
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY TO NEW CLIENTS. AND
WE'VE ALSO LEARNED THAT MANY
COUNTIES NOT CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN THE TSCH PRIOR
AND HAD DEVELOPED MISDEMEANOR I
ISSUED A VERSION PROGRAMS AND
PROTOCOLS THAT COULD BE
EXPANDED. TO INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING. POPULATION FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WERE REALLY BASING OUR
ASSUMPTIONS- EXACTLY ON THE
SAME ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE HAD
ESTABLISHED OUR ORIGINAL
PROGRAM IN. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN- BE FOR THE EXPANSION
OF THE- OUR EXISTING COUNTY
PROGRAMS THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
WOULD SUPPORT A 10220% INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF DIVERSION
CLIENTS SERVED. ABOVE THEIR
CURRENT ESTABLISHED POPULATION
TARGET. IN ADDITION- TO THE
PROPOSED EXPANSION WE ARE
REQUESTING TO EXTEND THEIR
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING FOR THE
ORIGINAL PROGRAM BY TWELVE
MONTHS AT THIS TIME WE ESTIMATE
THAT UP TO EIGHT MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND WILL NOT
ENCUMBERED BY AND- OF. THIS
FISCAL YEAR. THIS REQUEST WILL
ALLOW THE SHN CUMBER ANY
REMAINING CONTRACT RUNS THROUGH
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND TO
DISTRIBUTE ALL FUNDING TO
COUNTIES- THAT'S THE NINETY
NINE POINT FIVE MILLION THREE
G. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. REALLY
MULTIPLE IMPACTS FROM WHO THE
NINETEEN DELAYED OR DERAILED
ARE COUNTY PROGRAMS THROUGH THE
SPRING AND SUMMER TWENTY
TWENTY. ENCOUNTERS ALSO
EXPERIENCE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION DELAYS DUE TO
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL TIME TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS INFRASTRUCTURE
AND EXECUTE THEIR SUBCONTRACTS.
THE ADDITIONAL TWELVE MONTHS
REQUESTED MODOC GRANT DSHS
WHICH IS IN YOUR HANDS ENOUGH
TIME TO COMPLETE. THE PROGRAM
THROUGH THEIR FULL THREE YEAR
TERM OF THE PILOT. ADDITIONALLY
DST ME ONE. THE USE OF THE
HUNDRED NINE OR PER. BY ALEX
THE WAY WHEN ON ALLOCATE.
PROGRAM FUNDING TO COUNTIES
WITH THE CAPACITY TO SERVE MORE
POSSIBLE PROGRAMS. AND THEN MY-
PRESENTATION ON THE REQUEST YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. AS DR
BURDEN ANYTHING FOR YOU AT THIS
TIME JOINT EITHER JUST DO WANT
TO HEAR HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF NEEDED. YES
QUESTIONS THAT NEEDED THANK YOU
OKAY DEPARTMENT FINANCE. LMAO
THE CAMPAIGN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I THINK WHEN WE WERE
LOOKING AT- THE REGIONAL
PROPOSAL FROM GOVERNOR BROWN
FOR ISC DIVERSION I THINK THERE
WERE SOME QUESTIONS AS TO
EXACTLY HOW MUCH COST SAVINGS
WE ACTUALLY GET FROM THE
PROGRAM- THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME
SOMEWHAT OPTIMISTIC PROJECTIONS.
BUT I DO KNOW THAT- AND PROCEED
WITH DOING AN EVALUATION- TO BE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW PART OF THE
FUNDING IS TO HAVE A- RESEARCH
CONTRACT. BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT
IT'S A FIVE YEAR CONTRACT AND I
KNOW THAT WITH A THREE YEAR
PILOT YOU NEED SOME DATA
COLLECTION ETCETERA ARE WE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO. GET SOME
OF THESE PRELIMINARY DATA PRIOR
TO THE FIVE YEARS AS TO THE
COST EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE
EFFORTS- SO MAKE MAKE NOTE THAT
ARE SENATE TERMS ONLY FOR
YEARS- SO A FIVE YEAR CUT YOU
KNOW ARE YOU SEE. THAT WE DO A
LOT OF MORE COMPLETE REPORT- AT
FIVE YEARS BUT- CAN YOU. SPEAK
TO THE KIND OF FEEDBACK WE WILL
BE GETTING AS A LEGISLATOR IN
THIS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE IN
TERMS OF COST EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE OF. THOSE PROGRAMS- AS IT
IS IT'S ROLLING OUT. YOU'RE
CERTAINLY COLLECTING- DATA FROM
OUR COUNTIES NOT ONLY JUST THE
DEMOGRAPHIC AND- SERVICE
DELIVERY DATA THAT'S REQUIRED
BY STATUTE BUT WE ARE ALSO
COLLECTING- FINANCIAL DATA.
THAT'S MORE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
SO THAT WE CAN ONE COMPARE IT
TO THE ORIGINAL PLANS THAT THE
COUNTIES WERE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT TO US- AND THEN ALSO TO
EVALUATE- IF THOSE FUNDS ARE
BEING LEVERAGED- TO DRIVE DOWN
SAY ADDITIONAL MEDIC HOW
DOLLARS IF THERE'S USES AN HSA
DOLLARS. WHAT WE- DO YOU KNOW
SO I GUESS TO ANSWER YOUR YOUR
QUESTION WE WILL HAVE SOME
INFORMATION IN TERMS- COSTS-
AND CAN COMPARE THAT TO SAY THE
COST OF CARE IN THE STATE
HOSPITAL- AND THEN- YOU CAN
ALSO COMPARE IT TO- THE. COST
OF OTHER PROGRAMS THAT. NUMBER
EIGHTY CENTS SO I THINK WHAT WE
LOOKING SOME OF THE ARE TALK
ABOUT IS. THE REASON WAS JUST
TO TRY TO MOVE- NOT HAVE
PATIENCE END UP IN STATE
HOSPITALS ARE ARE HAVING A
BACKLOG AT CETERA SELF. I HOPE
THAT- YOU KNOW THE FUTURE
PRESENTATIONS AND I REALIZE
THAT THIS YEAR ALSO THERE ARE
STILL DELAYS HAPPEN BECAUSE A
COVETED CETERA. BUT I THINK IT.
IT IN PRESENTATIONS EACH YEAR
AND- IN THE FUTURE THAT WE
WOULD HAVE A- AND- AS TO YOU
KNOW HOW THIS INVESTMENT IS
ACTUALLY HELP TO REDUCE-
BACKLOGS AND- CASELOADS. IN IT
AND- IT TO THE STATE HOSPITALS
AND SO FORTH TWENTY I FOR THIS
GROUP OF. PATIENTS AND- THAT
THEY'RE GETTING ABLE TO GET
CARE MORE UP IN THE GROUND- AND-
COUNTY SO- SO I JUST HOPE THAT-
WE CAN HAVE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION AS THIS PROGRAM IS
ROLLING OUT AND NOT HAVE TO
WAIT FOR THE END OF A FIVE YEAR
EVALUATION. BEFORE WE HAVE THAT
KIND OF INFORMATION. OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WILL WILL NOTE THAT GOING
FORWARD. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN. SHE
NUMBER SIX THE COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION PROGRAM EXPANSION.
AGAIN PRESIDENT'S DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FORENSIC SERVICES
WELCOME BACK HI. THE DEPARTMENT
IS REQUESTING NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN THE CURRENT YEAR TO
EXPAND OUR EXISTING CD
OPPORTUNITY BASED RESTORATION
PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I
IN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED BEDS-
TO SERVICE S. T. POPULATION. IN
ADDITION THIS FUNDING REQUEST
PROVIDES TIME LIMITED
TRANSITIONAL RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT WHAT WE CALL THE
OFFERING. M. I. S. T.
DEFENDANTS ARE TO THE COMMUNITY
WHO MAKE ART RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY WHILE THEY'RE STILL
WAITING IN JAIL- AND THEN WE
ASSUME A PHASED APPROACH FOR
THE ACTIVATION OF THESE NEW
BEDS OVER A FORTY FIVE MONTH
PERIOD- I WILL SAY THAT THE
ASSUMPTIONS- IN THIS IN THIS
PROPOSAL DID ASSUME H. I
BELIEVE FEBRUARY- ACTIVATION WE
ARE SLIGHTLY DELAYED- BUT ARE.
INTOXICATING IN THIS NEXT MONTH
ACTIVATION ACTIVATE- IN
ADDITION WE ARE REQUESTING FOR
A HALF MILLION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND FIVE MILLION I'M GOING
TO EXPAND THIS PROGRAM BY AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY BAD. TO OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE- UP WITH AND
THEN YOU COUNTIES THAT WERE
ENGAGING THIS YEAR UP TO TWENTY
BEDS WILL ACTIVATE BY JULY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR WITH THE
REMAINING THIRTY PARENTS. ARE
TO BE ACTIVATED BY OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO SUPPORT
THE EXPANSION OF THESE PROGRAMS
WERE ALSO REQUESTING ONE
POSITION WHO- WILL SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND ONGOING
MANAGEMENT OF THESE PROGRAMS.
AS WELL AS THE EXISTING LA CPR
PROGRAM WHICH WE DID NOT
REQUEST STAFF RESOURCES TO- IN
ADDITION THIS REQUEST WOULD
SUPPORT- AN INCREASE IN TRAVEL
COSTS FOR A POSITION TO SUPPORT
OUTREACH PROGRAM PLANNING
PROGRAM ACTIVATION AS WELL AS
PROGRAM EVALUATION. LASTLY WE-
THIS REQUEST INCLUDES SOME
CONTRACT DOLLARS TO SUPPORT-
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THE FUNDING
ASSUMPTIONS FOR- OUR OUR
EXPANSION OF THE BADS ARE
REALLY- BASED ON THE EXPERIENCE
AN ACTUAL COSTS- FROM OUR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PROGRAM. AND AS
WELL AS AS EXPERIENCED IN
OPERATING- AND WHAT WE KNOW
FROM OUR ACTIVATED- FELONY
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION
PROGRAMS. I WOULD NOTE ON THE
NAVIGATIONAL RESOURCES FORD ON
THE COUNTIES IN THIS REQUEST-
MAYBE ADD- IF THE COMMUNITY
CARE DEMONSTRATION PROJECT
PROPOSAL WHICH I WILL NOT TALK
ABOUT LATER IN THIS
PRESENTATION WAS NOT APPROVED.
SO IN CONJUNCTION WITH OUR
DIVERSION PROGRAM AS WELL AS
OUR G. C. T. PROGRAMS THE
INITIATIVE WILL EXPAND THE
CAPACITY TO TREAT I ISSUES IN
THE COMMUNITY I REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF PATIENTS PENDING
PLACEMENT TO DS EACH
FACILITIES. AND WILL SUPPORT
THE OVERALL ROSE- AND GOLDUST
REDUCING EMISSION TIMES FOR
TREATMENT. IN MY PRESENTATION
ANY QUESTIONS. A DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. HELLO. NO I THINK
WE'RE I THINK WE'LL MOVE ON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT ISSUE
MEDIA HERE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT FOR TWENTY HIGHEST TEEN
I'M JOINED BY THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT STEPHANIE. WHO
WILL COME BACK OKAY. MY GOD
HELP ME AGAIN CAN YOU HEAR ME
YOUR- ALL RIGHT THANK YOUNG AND
JUST I WOULD BE FORCED ON THEM
I DO WANT TO RESPOND TO DR
PEONS A QUESTION EARLIER THIS
CASE THAT DATES WERE ABOUT
SEVENTY EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN TOTAL. THANK YOU FOR
THAT PARTICULAR. I'M ON. IT
SOBRE ISSUE SEVEN OF THE
COMMUNITY CARE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT FOR FELONY I. S. TEENS
THE DEPARTMENT HAS CONTINUED TO
EXPERIENCE A WAIT LIST FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL. AND
HER PENDING ADMISSION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM. OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS IN RESPONSE TO THE
INCREASING REFERRALS THE
DEPARTMENT ACTIVATED ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY IN ITS STATE
HOSPITALS. WE HEARD I MISS EVEN
TALK ABOUT THE DIVERSION
PROGRAM WE ARE WORKING TO
ESTABLISH WE PARTNERED WITH A
COUNTY SHERIFF'S TO STOMP THE
JAIL BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AND CONTRACTED AS WE
JUST HEARD WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO. PROVIDE COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION PROGRAMS.
EACH OF THESE EFFORTS HAS BEEN
IN AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASING REFERRALS TO THE
DEPARTMENT. HOWEVER DESPITE ALL
OF OUR EFFORTS THE REFERRALS
CONTINUE TO GROW AND EXCEED
CAPACITY- PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL THAT
WERE PENDING PLACEMENT TO AND
STATE HOSPITAL BED- HOVERED
AROUND EIGHT HUNDRED. WE WERE
SEEING THAT NUMBER I'D BE
DECREASE AND WE HAD ADDITIONAL-
ACTIONS THAT WE HAD PLANNED-
THAT WE WERE EXACERBATED THAT
WOULD CONTINUE TO DECREASE. BUT
SINCE THE PANDEMIC I'M DUE TO
ALL OF THE- IMPACTS OR
OPERATIONS INTO THE OPERATIONS
OF OTHERS THAT WE PARTNER WITH.
I WE'VE SEEN THIS NUMBER GROW
SIGNIFICANTLY- TODAY THE WAIT
LIST IS NEARLY SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED PATIENTS. AS A RESULT
OF THIS WEIGHTLESS THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE INCREASING COURT
PRESSURE ONTO TIMELY ADMIT IT
THE I. A. C. DEFENDANTS FOR
TREATMENT. OVER THE YEARS AND
HOUSE CONDUCT AND ALSO OF THE
I. POCKET TREE AND THAT'S- IN
THROUGH THIS AND- WE FOUND THE
MID. OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE OMITTED AS I S. T. HAVE NOT
RECEIVED SUFFICIENT MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PRIOR TO THEIR
ADMISSION. AND ARE CYCLING IN
AND OUT OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. APPROXIMATELY 50% HAD
NOT ACCESS COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT RESOURCES AND
THE SIX MONTHS PRIOR TO THEIR
ARREST. 45% HAD FIFTEEN OR MORE
PRIOR ARREST BEFORE BEING
COMMITTED TO D. S. H. ON THEIR
FELONY CHARGE AND ADDITIONALLY
NEARLY ONE HALF WERE
UNSHELTERED HOMELESS AT THE
TIME OF THE REST. SO THIS YEAR
THE DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING TO
ESTABLISH THE COMMUNITY CARE
COLLABORATIVE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT OR INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL AND WE'RE REQUESTING TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE POINT
TWO MILLION IN GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND FOUR
POSITIONS. AND A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX POINT FOUR MILLION
ONGOING FOR THIS EFFORT. AND
UNDER THIS DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT WE WOULD CONTRACT WITH
COUNTIES TO ASSUME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CARE AND
TREATMENT OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN FOUND I S. T. ON
FELONY CHARGES FROM THEIR
COUNTY. THROUGH THIS
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT WE SEEK
TO PROMOTE A COMMUNITY BASED
CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR FELONY I
IS T. DEPENDENCE. IN THE STATE
BACK TO SUPPORT THE PRINCIPLES
OF THE INSTITUTIONALIZATION FOR
DEFENDANTS WHO CAN BE BEST
CARED FOR IN LEAST RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS IN THE COMMUNITY WHILE
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE
GOING TO BE SOME DEFENDANTS
WITH CERTAIN VIOLENT CHARGES
THAT MAY NEED TO BE TREATED AND
SECURED FACILITIES INCLUDING
JAIL BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. OR STATE HOSPITALS. I
WE ALSO SEEK TO DEMONSTRATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS WITH STREAMLINED
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE LINE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT AT THE
COUNTY LEVELS FOR THIS
POPULATION TO DRIVE IMPROVED
OUTCOMES. SUCH AS REDUCED
INCARCERATION AND RECIDIVISM.
AND HOMELESSNESS FOR THIS
POPULATION. WE ALSO I WANT TO
PROMOTE INCREASED. WITHIN THEIR
EXIST COUNTY FUNDING STREAMS TO
LAMINATE SILENT APPROACHES TO
THE DELIVERY OF TREATMENT FOR
SERVICES FOR. INDEPENDENT
INDIVIDUALS NOT COMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL. AND PROVIDE TIMELY
RESTORATION OF COMPETENCY FOR
AYE IS DEPENDENT STATEWIDE AND
BETTER OVERALL OUTCOMES FOR
DEPENDENTS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS WERE JUSTICE INVOLVED.
IN THIS ALSO THIS PROPOSAL WHAT
WE ALSO SEEK TO REDUCE OUR
RISK- FOR LEGAL FINES AND
CONTEMPT FINDINGS BY THE
COURTS. SO I'M GONNA ACTUALLY
TURNED THIS OVER AGAIN AND TO
DEBBIE DIRECTOR EVENINGS WHO'S
GOING TO PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL
DETAILS ABOUT THE- PROPOSAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU THIS
PROPOSAL- OUR ASSUMPTIONS DO
YOU- DO YOU ASSUME THAT
TRANSITION COULD OCCUR AS SOON
AS JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. HE FEATURES OF THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDE. ONE ONGOING
FUNDING AS SO TO LIMIT THE RISK
OF BUILDING OUT NEW PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY
Q. ONE TIME FUNDS TO SUPPORT
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS BY
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES AND READ
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH THE
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SUPPORT THAT WE THAT
WILL BE PROVIDED BY. WILL BE A
STAGE AS WELL AS CONTRACTED
EXPERTS- SO REALLY WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING HERE IS THAT A
HOLISTIC FUNDING PACKAGE THAT
PROVIDES- THE FUNDING FOR THE
TREATMENT SERVICES HOUSING AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES- REALLY
CHáVEZ ME OUT BEST NEED NEEDS
OF THIS POPULATION- WHICH
REALLY OFTEN REPRESENT OUR
HIGHEST WEISS'S. IN THE SYSTEM.
THE FUNDING FOR THIS PROJECT
PROPOSES AS A MENTION ON GOING
BASELINE FUNDING FOR
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES WITH
SOME OF THOSE ONE TIME THAT
INVESTMENTS THE BASELINE
FUNDING. IS BASED ON A FIXED
RATE WHICH IS EQUIVALENT TO THE
COST OF TREATING AND I. S. T.
PATIENT IN THE STATE HOSPITAL
THAT. ANNUAL FUNDING WOULD BE
BASED ON THIS FIXED RATE. AND
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF I. S. T. IS
ESTIMATED TO BE COMMITTED BY
THE OUNTY- AND THAT ESTIMATE
IS REALLY BASED ON AN AVERAGE
AND PRIOR THREE YEARS AN ACTUAL
I. S. T. COMMITMENTS REFERRED
TO D. S. H. AT THIS TIME THAT-
HOSPITAL DUTY DEATH RATE IS. IS
SIX NINETY NINE- AND BASED ON
OUR LENGTH OF STAY B. FIXED
RATE IS A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND THREE FORTY FIVE. IN
ADDITION TO ONGOING FUNDS UP TO
THIRTY FIVE MILLION IN ONE TIME
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION FUNDS-
WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE WHICH
CAN BE USED TO SUPPORT ALL
STARTED COSTS INCLUDING
RECRUITMENT HIRING TRAINING OF
NEW STAFF. AS WELL AS THOSE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS THAT
I MENTIONED EARLIER. ON THE
FIRST YEAR WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
ONE TIME FINDING- CURRENTLY
ESTIMATED AT FORTY NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS ON THE DS
EACH WEEK REST AS OF JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
RIGHT NOT YET ADMITTED TO A D.
S. EACH PROGRAM. THAT ESTIMATE
IS BASED ON- AN ESTIMATED FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILES. IN
ADDITION WE WOULD PROPOSE TO
TRANSFER ANY FINDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PREVIOUSLY
COMMITTED TO COUNTIES- BROUGH
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
PREVIOUSLY COMMITTED TO COUNTY
SIR OTHER CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENT
SO FOR EXAMPLE I HAD MENTIONED
AND I JUST TALKED ABOUT OUR
DIVERSION PROGRAMS IF ONE OF
OUR PARTICIPATING COUNTIES
UNDER DISCUSSION. DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT IS CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN OUR DIVERSION
PILOT PROGRAM- WHILE NOTHING
WILL CHANGE IN TERMS OF THE
REQUIREMENT OF THAT PROGRAM- WE
WOULD PROPOSE TO JUST SHIFT
OVER THE BALANCE AND
EVERYTHING- TOOK THAT COUNTY
UNDER THAT CONTRACT BUT FOLDED
UNDER ONE SORT OF SINGULAR
CONTRACT. AS PART OF THE CCD.
AND SO THEN AGAIN AS PART OF
THIS PROJECT WE ARE PROPOSING
AN INITIAL THREE YEAR
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS- THAT
WOULD RUN THROUGH FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
COUNTIES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT COMMUNITY TREATMENT
PROGRAM PLANS. AND EXPENDITURE
REPORTS ANNUALLY AND ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS AND THEY WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
DEMOGRAPHIC IN TREATMENT DATA
AGAIN VERY CONSISTENT WITH OUR
DIVERSION PROGRAM- OUR
EVALUATION OF WILL REALLY AS-
STEPHANIE MENTIONED THAT-
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF.
STREAMLINING THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO DRIVE
IMPROVED OUTCOMES- AS WELL AS
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE FUNDING METHODOLOGY APPLIED
TO REASSESS THE BASELINE
FUNDING ALLOCATED TO EACH
COUNTY. AS WELL AS CONSIDER ANY
CHANGES TO THE OVERALL GROWTH
IN THE COUNTY POPULATION OR
COST OF CARE FACTORS THAT MIGHT
TRADE INCREASES OUTSIDE OF THE
TOWN'S CONTROL. I THINK I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT COUNTIES WERE TALKING WITH
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE EVERY
LEVEL OF CARE THAT'S READILY
AVAILABLE IN TIME FOR A JULY
TWENTY ONE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ACTIVATION- BUT SO WITH THAT WE
FULLY EXPECT THAT THE CONTINUUM
SERVICES UTILIZED IN THE FIRST
AND SECOND YEAR OF THE PROGRAM
MAY LOOK VERY DIFFERENT AND IT
WILL BE IN FUTURE YEARS
PARTICULARLY AS OTHER-
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS IN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUAL ARE
MADE. IN YOUR ARMS. I SO WITH
RESPECT TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED IN THE AGENDA- THE
FIRST QUESTION HOW WITH THIS
PROGRAM INTERACT WITH THE
PREVIOUS HIGHEST YOU DIVERSION
PROGRAM AND THE LA. COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION PROGRAM THAT
WAS AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- I THINK I NOTED
EARLIER ANY OTHER CONTRACTED DS
EACH PROGRAM- THAT
PARTICIPATING COUNTY AS AN- OLD
WEST- WOULD BECOME PART AT THE
OVER ALL CCG- FOR EXAMPLE. ME
HAS A DIVERSE CONTRA- THEN WE
TRANSFER ALL OF THOSE REMAINING
BALANCES FUNDS SIMILARLY IF
THEY COUNTY- HAS A COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION PROGRAM OR
JAIL BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
WE WOULD TRANSFER THOSE
PROGRAMS. SHOULD BE COUNTY
RESPONSIBILITY. THE SECOND
QUESTION HOUSE YEARS EACH BOARD
MEETING WITH OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND ENTITIES
INCLUDING MAC HOW AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AS WELL AS HOW TO BE
ABLE HEALTH PROGRAMS TO
COORDINATE OTHER STATE. AND
LOCAL. INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WOULD BE NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION- WELL
WE'VE MET- ACTUALLY MULTIPLE
TIMES WITH OUR- SISTER
DEPARTMENTS DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AS WELL AS
COMPARTMENT AND SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO DISCUSS- THE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE IN THERE BY
CHANCE IN THE INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE REALLY BEING MADE- BY THE
THEY- BE ADMINISTRATION IN THE
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SPACE- AND SO WHILE OUR
PROPOSAL- THE CCG. AND THE
OTHER. PROPOSED ARE ON SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT TIMELINES I WOULD
NOTE THAT OUR- ARE PROPOSAL
REALLY OFFICE FINDING. OFFER A
VERY SPECIFIC POPULATION THAT
WILL NECESSARILY BE THE SERVICE
BY THE OTHER PROPOSALS- BUT WE
ARE CERTAINLY OR NEEDING- SO
THAT- WE ARE AVOIDING- WHERE WE
CAN'T ANY DUPLICATION OF
EFFORTS- AND THEN SINCE THE
RELEASE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE'VE MATT WITH MULTIPLE
COUNTIES- CONSIDERING
PARTICIPATION IN THIS PROGRAM.
WE'VE ALSO MET WITH VARIOUS
ASSOCIATIONS TO DATE THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- USING CITIES HAVE
PROVIDED US WITH SOME FEEDBACK
ON THE CREDIT FILE PROJECT AND
WE'RE TAKING THAT FEEDBACK INTO
CONSIDERATION. FOR THE ME
REVISED- AND- WE WILL ALSO AS
PART OF MAY REVISE ANNOUNCE ANY
COUNTIES THAT HAVE AGREED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THISPROGRAM- AS
PART OF THAT PROCESS. AND THEN
WE CONTINUE TO SEE THE PROCESS
OF REACHING OUT OR NEEDING
MEETINGS WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO DISCUSS THIS
PROPOSAL- SO FOR EXAMPLE- THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION JUDICIAL
COUNCIL- AS THERE IS SOME
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
ACCOMPANIES THIS PROPOSAL THAT.
REALLY OFF AUTHORIZES THE
PROGRAM AND ALSO PROPOSES SOME
CHANGES TO THE PENAL CODE
THIRTEEN SEVENTY TWO CREATED
PATHWAY FOR THE COURTS TO
REFERRED TO FELLAINI ICE YOU
POPULATION TO THE PARTICIPATING
COUNTIES. RATHER THAN DIRECTLY.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS- QUESTION I'M THREE
DESCRIBE HOW THE INCENTIVES FOR
COUNTIES WOULD WORK TO PROMOTE
INTERVENTIONS PRIOR TO FELONY I
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT- WELL THIS
PROGRAM REALLY DIFFERS
SIGNIFICANTLY THAN OUR-
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAD PUT FORTH
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET PROCESS.
AND THAT WAS CALLED THE
COMMUNITY CARE COLLABORATIVE HI
LINDA CCC HE- VERY SIMILAR-
WHILE THE MAIN GOAL AND THE
CCCP WAS INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES
TO CREATE UPSTREAM
INTERVENTIONS. FELONY JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT THE MAIN GOAL OF
THIS CURRENT PROJECT IS REALLY
TO GIVE COUNCILS ALL THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO SUPPORT
A FULL CONTINUUM OF CARE IN THE
COMMUNITY- AND- APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT FOR THAT SELLING Y.
S. T. POPULATION. ON THE FAT
FUNDING METHODOLOGY FOR THIS
PROGRAM USES AN AVERAGE COST OF
CARE I S. T. IN A STATE
HOSPITAL- WHICH WE FEEL IS
HIGHER THAN THE COST OF WHAT
THE CARE WOULD BEIN LOWER
LEVELS OF CARE. IN THAT ENGINE
UNITY AS WELL AS THE COST OF
THE GOP'S COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAM. AND SO WHILE CHINESE
WILL STILL HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
HIGHER COSTS BADS- AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
IF THE RESOURCES ARE MANAGED
RIGHT AND WE HAVE- ALSO
CONTINUAL OF THE LOWER LEVEL-
THIS RESTRICTED BAD. SMALLER
COST FADS- THE COUNTY'S CALL.
RELY SAVINGS EACH YEAR- US
THROUGH THIS PER- HOWEVER CV WE
PROPOSE ANY- WE WOULD. A WITH
THE COW TO BE REINVESTED IN
THOSE UPSTREAM OR DOWNSTREAM ON
SUCH AS RE ENTRY PROGRAMS TO
PREVENT FELONY JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT FOR PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS- AND SO.
THIS IN TURN HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO CREATE ADDITIONAL SAVINGS
THAT CAN BE INVESTED BECAUSE WE
CAN BE YOUR DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT WILL GUARANTEE COUNTY
AS A MINIMUM LEVEL OF FUNDING
REGARDLESS OF THE NUMBER OF
ACTUAL SELLING UNITS TO BE
SERVED IN HERE. AND SO THE
COUNTY IS ABLE TO REDUCE AS
WELL THE NUMBER OF I. S. G.
COMMITMENTS EACH YEAR THERE
FUNDING THROUGH THE S. H. WOULD
REMAIN THE SAME AND ADDITIONAL
FUNDS CAN THEN BE APPLIED TO
THOSE UPSTREAM AND- DOWNSTREAM
PROGRAMS. ANY QUESTIONS- THE
FIRST THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
LMAO END UP THERE MR SHOULD.
THANK YOU AND CENTER EGGMAN
ACCORDING WITH THE L. A. O. OUR
OFFICE IS RECENTLY PUBLISHED AN
ANALYSIS OF THIS PROPOSAL WHICH
IS AVAILABLE ON OUR ON OUR
WEBSITE- WORK WE'RE ACTUALLY
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL WHILE WE DON'T HAVE
ISSUES WITH THE CONCEPT OF
MAKING COUNTIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
TREATING FELONY ICE TEAS- WE
FIND THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS NOT
WELL STRUCTURED TO ACHIEVE ITS
INTENDED GOALS- FOR EXAMPLE THE
CCP'S FUNDING MECHANISM. MAKES
WHETHER COUNTIES WILL HAVE
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES. FOR THE POINT THAT
THEY COMMIT AN OFFENCE YOU KNOW
SORT OF THOSE UPSTREAM SERVICES
THAT WORD THAT WE JUST
DISCUSSED- SUBJECT TO
CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY IN
ADDITION WE FIND THAT THE
INCENTIVES FOR COUNTIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROJECT ARE
ARE UNCLEAR AND- THE PROPOSAL
ALSO PROVIDES ON GOING FUNDING
TO- A PROJECT PRIOR TO THE
POINT WHEN AN EVALUATION CAN BE
DONE ON ITS EFFECTIVENESS- THIS
EASY PEASY. ALSO OVERLAP WITH
SEVERAL EXISTING PROGRAMS IN D.
S. H. THROUGH WHICH COUNTIES
PROVIDE TREATMENT TO FELONY ICE
TEAS- WE FIND THIS RAISES
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE VALUE ADD
OF THIS- PROPOSAL WHEN COMPARED
TO. YOU KNOW EXISTING PROGRAMS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN FUNDED IN
PRIOR YEARS- GIVEN THESE
CONCERNS WE THINK IT MAKES
SENSE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
REJECT THIS PROPOSAL- SHOULD
THE LEGISLATURE WISH TO PROVIDE
MORE FUNDING TO COUNTIES FOR
COMPETENCY RESTORATION
TREATMENT- WE WOULD RECOMMEND
DIRECTING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO- EXISTING PSH PROGRAMMES FOR
THAT PURPOSE- IN REGARDS TO
PROVIDING INDIVIDUALS-
PROVIDING TREATMENT INDIVIDUALS
ON THE FRONT END BEFORE THEY
COMMIT OFFENSES THAT COULD.
RENDER THEM I A CD- WE FIND
THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER
PROPOSALS IN THE BUDGET THAT
MAKES SORT OF MORE DIRECT
INVESTMENTS IN COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES THAT.
WOULD BE MORE EFFECTIVE AT
REACHING SORT OF THIS THIS-
POPULATION IS SORT OF AT
PARTICULAR RISK OF BEING FOUND
I. S. T. FOR EXAMPLE THE NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL IN DH
CS FOR BEAVER HEALTH
FACILITIES- OR THE PROPOSED
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT
BENEFITING MANY CALENDAR
CALLIE- WHICH WOULD BE TARGETED
AT JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS- SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE WISH TO MAKE THIS A
PRIORITY. YOU KNOW WE FIND AN
ALTERNATIVE STRATEGY COULD BE
TO EXPLORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR D.
S. H. TO WORK WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO BUILD. REALLY
SORT OF I. S. T. SPECIFIC
ISSUES INTO- SORT OF. THESE
THESE OTHER PROPOSALS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT'S ALONG
LINES MEANS. YOU HAVE THE OF
THE DISADVANTAGE OF COMING
THAT. WE'VE ALREADY HEARD SOME
OF THE OTHER PROPOSALS FROM
SOME OF THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS-
IT'S GONNA BE. THERE THE FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS THAT WERE
ALL LOOKING AT AND CALLING THAT
WE'RE ALL LOOKING AT. AND I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND YOUR- YOU
KNOW AND I THINK YOU'VE BEEN
PUSHED TO TRY TO- IDENTIFY
THESE FOLKS BEFORE. THEY'VE YOU
KNOW THEY'VE COME TO THE
ATTENTION FIFTEEN TIMES BEFORE
YOU GET THEM. YOU KNOW AND I
AND I GUESS I JUST JUST SITTING
HERE AT WITH. THE PROBLEMS THAT
WERE WERE GRAPPLING WITH- BUT
WE'RE ALL GRAPPLING WITH THAT.
W. E. I MEAN I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE THE FLOOD OR THE DAM BUT
YEAR WHERE THINGS GET BACKED UP
WHEN WE DON'T DO ALL OF OUR
WORK ON THE FRONT END OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY- SO I GUESS AND-
I GUESS I. BUT WE UNDERSTAND
YOUR YOUR DESIRE AND YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY. TO SERVICE
POPULATION AND DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT WITH THE HUGE BACKLOG.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THERE'S A
LOT OF OTHER PROPOSALS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ON THE
TABLE. TO TRY TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE SAME ISSUES. I'M THE ONE
RESPOND A LITTLE BIT TO THE L.
A. O. OR- OR NOT AT THIS TIME.
EITHER ENOUGH EITHER FOR THAT
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FOR THE
DEPUTY. I'LL START AND THEN.
PASS IT OVER TO PRESS IF SHE
HAS ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS BUT
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS I
WOULD JUST NOTE IN THE-
RECOMMENDATION TO INVEST
FURTHER IN THE STRATEGIES- AND
WE DO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
STRATEGY. ALL OF THE STRATEGIES
AROUND- I. S. TEASE AND IT WE
DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE ON
DIVERSION AS WELL AS FOR- A
COMMUNITY BASED ON GBC T. IS
THAT WE WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
FINDING IN OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COUNTY IS THAT THOSE
THAT HAVE. BUILT SOME OF THIS
CONTINUUM ALREADY AND I'VE
ALREADY BEEN OUR PARTNERS ARE
ARE PROBABLY THE ONES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE BEST SUITED FOR
MOVING INTO TAKING OVER
RESPONSIBILITY THEY. HAVE
EXPERIENCE READING THEM AND-
BUT FAR AS JUST. TWENTY IN THE
THESE STRATEGIES- WHAT WE HAVE
NOW IS. WE HAVE BEEN BEFORE THE
COMMITTEES ARE BUDGET
COMMITTEES AND YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR ASKING FOR IN
COMPANIES AND PROPERTY AND
BUILDING CAPACITY TO SERVE IT
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM. I'M EIGHT
THROUGH THESE PARTNERSHIPS. BUT
WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT THE
RATES OF REFERRALS CONTINUE. TO
INCREASE- YEAH THIS YEAR IS AS-
INCREASES MARGINALLY MOSTLY AND
SAY IT'S ALL COKE RIGHT. BUT IN
THE PRIOR YEARS AS WE DEVELOP
OUR CAPACITY WE SIGN THE
NUMBERS CONTINUE TO INCREASE
AND SO I AM MOVING THAT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE COUNTY.
WHAT THAT DOES IS GIVES ME
COUNTY BACK MY FULL CONTROL THE
THAT THE UNDERSTANDING THE
ABILITY TO THE KIND OF ALL THE
PARTNERS WORKING TOGETHER TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND. WHERE THE
CHALLENGES ARE IN THE IN IN
THEIR THEIR CONTINUUM OF CARE
EONS- WHAT INVESTMENT
STRATEGIES THEY NEED TO DO TO
TARGET THIS POPULATION- WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT. YOU REALLY WHAT
WE SEE IS THAT OFTEN THE
ABILITY TO PUT SOMEBODY OUT OF
STATE HOSPITAL IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TREATMENT. AND
IN MANY CASES AND SO WE REALLY
WANT TO TRY TO AS DRESSED IN
THIS MYSTERY POPULATION THAT WE
AS THE DEPARTMENT APPLE
RESPONSIBILITY THE STATE OWNS
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR ANYBODY
WHO'S FOUND ANTHONY HOPKINS FAN
FROM. IS TO MOVE INTO AS THAT
THIS PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COUNTY SO THAT THEY ARE HAVING.
A ROLE IN ON AND HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO- A SERVICE
FASCICULATION INTO. WAY IN
PARTNERSHIP IN COLLABORATION
WITH ALL THE OTHER EFFORTS THAT
ARE BEING IN INVESTMENTS ARE
BEING MADE RAN. INTO ARE INTENT.
AND SO I'LL ASK AND DENTAL
DOCTOR EVEN IF SHE HAS ANY AN
ADDITIONAL. COMMENT SHE WANTS
ME. HERE YEAH I WOULD- WELL OF
THAT IS RIGHT WE ARE ARE EX
WITH DAVE AND- CDS THREE. WELL
I'LL SET CBO SITE YOU MEAN A
DIAPER AND WE HAVE- THAT. SHIPS
WITH THE COUNTY IS THAT THERE A
STRONG. TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
SORT OF THE BEST PRACTICES AND
TECHNIQUE THAT WILL BE SERVE A
SORT OF CRIME. WE A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE TALKING AND THAT'S THAT.
THAT WE BRING TO TABLE- I DO I
DO WITH. THAT IS MORE MORE
PARTICULARLY AROUND- THE WHOLE
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE DESIGNED TO- TO-
TAKE- WHATEVER IT TAKES
APPROACH AND SERVE THAT THAT
WILL JUST JUST POPULATION BUT
THERE ARE SOME SOME UNIQUE
NEEDS ARM OF. THE FELONY I S.
T. POPULATION- NOT SO UNIQUE
THAT THE COUNTIES ARE
INADEQUATE TO HANDLE- OR TAKE
CARE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS BUT I
THINK WHAT WHAT WE BRING. WITH
THIS PROPOSAL IS. AS I SAID
IT'S BOTH HAVE HOW. TREAT
SERVICES. FOR ALL DHABI. AS
WELL AS FORCE TO REALLY-
PROVIDED A SUPPORTIVE APPROACH
IN THE COUNTIES IN- GIVING THEM
BEAT YOU KNOW TA IN THE
TRAINING RESOURCES AND GET TO-
SUPPORT THEIR STAFF IN THE- IN
THE COMMUNITY AS THEIR AS THEIR
TEACHINGS OF. HE'S A MAJOR.
AND- I GUESS I WOULD ALSO SAY
IN TERMS OF JUST THE
DUPLICATION WE DON'T THERE IS
NO DUPLICATION OF SERVICES IN
TERMS OF GB CG AND COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION- ARE WE HAVE
BEEN VERY STRATEGIC ABOUT THESE
PROPOSALS IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
NEED TO- REALLY BE VERY
RESPONSIVE TO YOU OUR WAIT LIST
AND GROWING WEIGHT LISTS- AND
WE NEED. THE BIG BOLD-
PROPOSALS TO- TO TACKLE THIS
FROM EVERY ANGLE I GUESS IF YOU
WILL. AND SO WITH THAT
COMMUNITY CARE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT ON AS I MENTIONED IF
THERE ARE ANY EXISTING
CONTRACTS THAT SUCH AS A JAIL
BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAM OR COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION PROGRAM. THAT ALL
THOSE RESOURCES AND THOSE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS WILL BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO NOT
PARTICIPATING COUNTY TO CONTROL
THAT AND SISTER DIRECTLY SERVE
THEIR POPULATIONS- DS EACH WILL
RETAIN CONTROL OF ANY OTHER
PROGRAM THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THE
PARTICIPATING COUNTY SO ANYBODY
ELSE WHO- ARE ANY OTHER I. S.
T. CLIENT THAT IS BEING
REFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT. CAN
BE SERVED BY THOSE.
UNDERSTANDING PROGRAMS. DO NEED
A WE HAVE NUMBERS ON IT. AND
CONTROLLING FOR POPULATION
COUNTIES THAT HAVE MORE IN THIS
POPULATION THAN OTHERS SO I
GUESS I'M THINKING THAT
COUNTIES THAT HAVE REALLY GOOD
GOOD COMMUNITY SUPPORT SYSTEM
SET UP PERHAPS WOULDN'T HAVE AS
MANY REFERRALS INTO THIS WERE
ARE WE ABLE TO TRACK THAT
ACROSS THE STATE. WE DO TRACK-
WE DO TRACK ALL OF THE
REFERRALS THAT COME IN FROM
FROM ANY- COUNTY- I CAN'T SAY
THAT LEAVES IN TERMS OF LOOKING
BROADLY ACROSS. THE ENTIRE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUE ON
EACH OF THOSE COUNTIES- HAS
MADE YOU KNOW SORT OF
EVALUATIONS OR OBSERVATIONS IN
TERMS OF HOW THAT CORRELATES TO
BURN. RATE AND HIGHEST SHE
REFERRALS THAT COME TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
I GUESS WE CAN DRAW THE AT I
MEAN THAT THE CORRELATION BUT
IT WOULD SEEM THAT PEOPLE ARE
BETTER COUNTY SYSTEM SET UP
WOULD HAVE FEWER PEOPLE BEING
REFERRED TO THIS FIFTEEN TIMES
LATER- DEPARTMENT FINANCES YOUR
HAND UP. YES THANK YOU WE HAD
OUR RAMOS A PERMANENT FINANCE.
WHICH IS LIKE TO ASK WHILE AGO
A LOT OF THE COMMENTS. OUR
STATE. DEPARTMENT OF HOSPITALS
HAS. ON NOTED WE AGREE WITH THE
L. A. THAT INCREASING THE
FUNDING FOR EXISTING PROGRAMS
SUCH AS JB CTAS AND- CPR'S- HAS
MERIT. WE WILL NOTE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES OVER
THREE HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO DO JUST THAT. WE ALSO
AGREED THAT- INCLUDING EYES HE
SPECIFIC RESOURCES AND OTHER
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSALS. ALSO
HAS MERIT AND AS SUCH FOR
EXAMPLE THE CALAMP ENHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT. PORTION. INCLUDES-
AND- ARE INTO AT RISK CONSISTS
XIN SO- BACK INCLUDE RISK I
HE'S- HOWEVER WE THINK THAT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
ADDRESS THAT. AND THEN JUST THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO BETTER
ADDRESS THE ESCALATING OF
FELONY I ISSUE WEIGHTLESS. SO
WE HAVE PROPOSED THIS COMMUNITY
CARE DEMONSTRATION PROJECT
PROGRAM. OKAY WELL A LOT MORE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE STARTED
PANICKING TO TIME. THANK YOU I
THINK SILICON ESTIMATE FIRST OF
ALL TWO ITEMS AGO ALSO APPLY TO
THIS ONE BUT LET ME JUST ASK A
QUESTION THEN WE- WE ACTUALLY
HAD TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT TO AUTHORIZE THE HUNDRED
MILLION THERE SEVERAL COUNTIES
RIGHT THAT ARE GETTING FUNDING.
CORRECT NINETY ONE. IN- SO- I
JUST DID THAT MAKE THE CORE
ISSUE IS THE- I. S. T. BACKLOG.
SO AT THIS POINT IN TIME GIVEN
THIS FUNDING. WHAT IS. THE
OUTCOME WE'RE EXPECTING HOMES
WHAT REDUCTION AN ICY BACKLOG
SHOULD WE EXPECT AS THE
LEGISLATURE- FROM THE USE OF
THIS FUNDING AND IF YOU DON'T
ACHIEVE THAT AND I HOPE YOU
WOULD AGREE THEN WE SHOULD STOP
THE PROGRAM. SO WHAT IS THE
OUTCOME MEASURE IN WHICH WE
NEED TO CHIEF JUSTICE DECLARED
THIS PROGRAM A SUCCESS OR
FAILURE. SO THE FUNDING LEVEL
THAT'S PROPOSED AND I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE FUNDING LEVEL
I WON AND NUMBER FOR WHAT DE
ICED TEA BACKLOG SHOULD BE SO
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT TWO
YEARS NEXT YEAR WE SAY. THIS
PROGRAM WORKED OR DIDN'T WORK.
SO OUR ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO-
THEY MET INDIVIDUALS WITH AND-
AT LEAST GET DOWN TO SIX FEET
UNDER SIXTY DAYS I WHICH IS
CURRENTLY THE REQUIREMENTS
UNDER. THAT COURT DECISION BUT
ULTIMATELY THE SOONER THAT WE
CAN GET AND THE VISUALS INTO
TREATMENT FOR I. S. T. THAT'S
OUR ULTIMATE CALL BUT- THE
SUCCESS WE WOULD BE LOOKING FOR
IS LOOKING TO GET OUR IT IS OUR
MISSION TIMELINES FOR ALL OF
THAT POPULATION. UNDER THE AGE.
SO THAT WOULD CAUSE WHAT WOULD
THAT DO TO THE BACKLOG IF WE
DID THAT. SO THE NOT REALLY
DEPENDS ON WHAT THE ADMISSION
RATES ARE RIGHT SO IF YOU CAN
SET ARE AND AS WE BRING ON
CAPACITY OUR ADMISSION RATE
INCREASE. SO THAT NUMBER IS
ALWAYS CANDIDATES ENGINES ARE
REALLY HAD A LOOK AT WHAT
THEY'VE ALREADY MONTHS WORTH OF
EMISSIONS ARE YOU KNOW RATE IS.
ORDERED KNOW THAT YOUR AND YOUR
WEIGHT LIST IS WITHIN THAT OKAY.
I'M NOT NUMBER GONNA ALL KIND
OF MOVED AND ON THE LOWER
CAPACITY YEAH OKAY RIGHT SO.
WELL THERE'S WELL LET'S SITE
THE FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM IF
I AND CORRECTLY IS ACTUALLY TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM HAVING TO
GO AND RIGHT SO I REALIZE THAT.
YOUR OVERALL WAITLIST HìNH.
THE TIME ZONE MISSION IS
SOMEWHAT IS OBVIOUSLY MAY
FLUCTUATE DEPENDING ON THE
CAPACITY HAVE WITHIN THE
HOSPITAL. BUT AT LEAST WHAT A
UNDERSTAND UNLESS I HEARD WRONG
THE PURPOSE OF THIS FUNDING IS
ACTUALLY TO PREVENT PEOPE FROM
EVEN HAVING TO GO THERE TO YOU
TAKE CARE. OF IT AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL CORRECT. CORRECT OKAY ARE
SO. WHEN THINGS AND- THAT I
THINK IT'S GONNA BE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I AGAIN
APPRECIATE WHAT ELIA SAID AND
THIS IS BEEN A PROBLEM I THINK
FROM THE BEGINNING WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. WHEN I HEARD IT BACK
IN- IN THAT PRIOR BUDGET YEAR
IS THAT WE NEED MUCH CLEAR
METRICS. AS TO WHAT. GIVEN
AMOUNT OF MONEY WE'RE SPENDING
WE'RE GOING TO GET FOR THIS
MONEY. SO I REALIZE THERE MAY
BE DIFFERENT APPROACHES PEOPLE
MAY TAKE IN DIFFERENT COUNTIES
AND SO FORTH GIVEN WHAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE BUT
ULTIMATELY. WHAT IS GOING TO
CHANGE. AS A RESULT OF THIS SO
I REALIZE THAT YOU SAID YOU
WANT TO REDUCE YOUR- YOU KNOW
THE TIME- TO THE SIXTY DAYS
THAT'S CERTAINLY VERY
IMPORTANT- BUT SINCE IS A
PREVENTION PROGRAM I MEAN
HOPEFULLY WE'RE NOT KEEPING
THAT BECAUSE WE CHANGED A
PASSING HOSPITALS BECAUSE THEN
THAT'S WHERE WE SHOULD PUT THE
MONEY INTO THAT AND- WE'RE
TRYING TO. UNDERSTAND THIS THIS
FUNDING IS TO TRY TO PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM HAVING TO GO IN AND
SO. ASIDE FROM THE FLUCTUATIONS
IT MAY HAPPEN TO YOUR CAPACITY.
WHAT MEASURES DO WE HAVE THAT
ACTUALLY WILL. SHOW THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ACTUALLY BEING REFERRED.
INTO. IN THE INTERVENTION
COUNTIES CORRECT. SO IT GETS
MONEY JUST MAKE SURE. TO
CLARIFY THAT THAT THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS MAY STILL BE BURKE.
AN INCUMBENT IS DOWN FINAL BUT
WILL BE TREATED IN THE COUNCIL
SO- THERE IS A THERE MAYSTILL
BE THIS IS THE FINDINGS. BUT
THEY WILL BE AT IT ANY
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES WILL BE
TREATED IN THE COUNTY UNLESS
THEY REFER INDIVIDUALS TO US
AND IN IN THIS PROPOSAL WE
ESTIMATE ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT.
OF THE ICE TEAS WILL STILL
NEEDS TO BE REFERRED TO THE
PARK. I'M AT THE FUNDING LEVELS
PROPOSED. AS IF ALL IF WE ARE
ABLE TO CON A PARTNER WITH
ENOUGH YOUNG TEENS TO MEET THE
LEVEL OF THE- BUT- HE'S THAT
ARE RIGHT THAT ARE PROPOSED IN
THIS PROPOSAL. WE DO ANTICIPATE
THAT THIS WILL IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR- THAT COULD REDUCE
OUR WAITLIST DOWN TO A TIME
WHERE WE ARE. NEEDING THIS
SIXTY DAYS BUT IT'S ALL REALLY
DEPENDING UPON HOW MANY COUNTY
STEP UP BEYOND THAT THAT'S PART
OF. THAT RIGHT YOU ALSO ALREADY
HAVE A. CITY COUNTIES WERE ON
BOARD CORRECT. PARDON YOUR HAVE
A SAID IT STAR BOY CORRECT.
POLICE DEPARTMENT. SO FOR THIS
PROPOSAL STILL ACTUALLY AND
WITH COUNTIES WE DON'T ANYTHING
ON WALKING. OUT OKAY SO SINCE
WE PASSED TWENTY WE STILL DON'T
HAVE ANY COUNTIES ON BOARD. NO
THAT I'M MAKE SURE GROUP OUT OF
THEIR FOUR YEARS LATER I MEAN
THAT'S NOT GOING TO SEE THIS
NOT OF YOU PROPOSAL FOR THIS
YEAR THIS IS A PROPOSAL WE
HEARD BACK WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN
WAS STILL GOVERNOR SO YOU KNOW
GOVERNOR'S HAS BEEN IN OFFICE
FOR A LITTLE WHILE. ACTUALLY
TWO DIFFERENT PROPOSALS THE ONE
THAT WE JUST PRESENTED IS THE
COMMUNITY FAIR FIBER TO A
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT I'M NOT
OPPOSE ALL IS A BRAND NEW
PROPOSAL IN WHICH WE DO NOT
HAVE YOUR OWN VIEWS THIS IS FOR
THEM TO ASSUME RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF
ICE TEAS FROM THERE COUNTY. AND-THE PRIOR PROPOSAL THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO IS THAT THE
VERSION PROPOSAL RIGHT WHICH IS
SMALL SUBSET OF INDIVIDUALS-
WHO COULD BE FOUND INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL OR WHO MAY BE AT
RISK OF BECOMING IRAQI AND SO
THAT'S JUST A SMALL SUBSET IT
WAS ONLY AND- DESIGNED THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WAS
PROPOSING TO TREAT ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND- FIFTY INDIVIDUALS
ALTHOUGH READ THE CONTRACT.
COUNTIES THAT THEY HAVE- AT
COMMITTED TO SERVING A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER THAN THAT I'M
ANTECEDENTS PRESENTED BUT AND
THAT'S ITTHAT'S A SMALLER
SUBSET IT WAS ONLY DESIGNS READ
A SMALL. SUBSET THANK SO I
THINK I FOR AWHILE THE L. A.
PRISON- AND I THINK IF I HAD
MORE TIME TO DO. AT THE INTO IT
I THERE'S A LOT OF THAT. THE
LACK OF CRITICAL. IN TERMS OF
THE OUTCOME AND WE WOULD
MEASURE. WHETHER WE CHEESE THE
GOALS ARE NOT. SO HOPING THAT
BETWEEN NOW AND MAY REVISE YOU
CAN GREATER CLARITY- ELLIE- CAN
YOU JUST COMMENT TO MY ASKING
THE RIGHT LINE OF QUESTIONS ARE
NOT. YOU'RE SUGGESTING REJECT
THIS ALL TOGETHER BUT I MEAN I
SO YES. YEAH I THINK YOUR YOUR
LINE OF QUESTIONING MAKES MAKES
TOTAL SENSE AND THAT THERE
THERE SHOULD BE SORT OF MORE
CLARITY ON THE OUTCOMES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS- PROPOSAL-
I'D AS- THERE IS SORT OF A- I
DATA GATHERING IN DATA-
EVALUATION COMPONENT TO THIS
PROPOSAL AND- IT. I WOOD MAY BE
DEFERRED TO THE ADMINISTRATION
ON HOW TO SORT OF DESCRIBE-
DOPE THAT THOSE COMPONENTS OF
THE COMPOSED THE PROPOSAL. OUR
ISSUE WITH THE PROPOSAL IS- NOT
SORT OF WITH THE CONCEPT OF
MAKING COUNTIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT- FOR THIS FOR THIS TREATMENT
IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE STRUCTURE
AND DESIGN OF THE PROGRAM AND-
ITS SORT OF THE SET UP IN A WAY
THAT. MAKES WHETHER OR NOT
THESE THE SORT OF LIKE FRONT
END INVESTMENTS ARE- YOU KNOW
SUBJECT UNCERTAINTY IN AND- AB.
MAKES IT SO THAT YOU KNOW THE
INCENTIVES WHICH COUNTIES WILL
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL FIRST OF
ALL I THINK HAVING SOME CLEAR
OUTCOMES FOR WHATEVER THE
PROGRAM'S GOING TO BE IS GONNA
BE VERY IMPORTANT AND I THINK
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME CLARITY
AS TO- ALSO HOW THIS.
INTEGRATES BECAUSE OTHERWISE
WE'RE JUST GONNA SILO ICE WHEN
A FRAGMENT ALL THESE DIFFERENT
WE HAVE ALL THESE DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS THAT MAY BE
OVERLAPPING AND SO FORTH- WITH
SOME OF THE EXISTING ONES THAT
AGAIN WE'VE REALLY HEARD ABOUT
FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS. SO I
HOPE THAT WE CAN GET MUCH MORE
CLARITY ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT.
WE'RE DOING HERE I THINK THAT
IS CERTAINLY WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ACHIEVE IS NOT SOMETHING WE
DISAGREE WITH. US AT LEAST I'D
DISAGREE I WANT USE WE- DON'T
SPEAK FOR EVERYONE ELSE BUT- I
DO I DO. THINK THAT THERE'S
SOME LACK OF CLARITY AS TO WHAT
THE- GOALS ARE. AND OF HOW DO
WE MEASURE WHETHER. THIS
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT. SO HAVING
CLARITY ON THAT AND THEN HAVING
SOME MORE CLARITY ON HOW THIS
THEN WILL INTERFACE WITH ALL
THE OTHER PROGRAM SO WE'RE NOT
DOING DUPLICATION OR
FRAGMENTATION. AS WELL AND YOU
KNOW WE HAVE BOTH THE DIVERSION
PROGRAM WHICH IS WITHIN THIS
PARTICULAR YOUR DEPARTMENT'S
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE COUNTY
WE'VE OTHER TYPES OF PROGRAMS
AS WELL. YOU KNOW AND EACH OF
US AS SO FORTH SO. I THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL- TO BE
ABLE TO CLARIFY. BEFORE
PROVING- SOMETHING THAT'S- AT
THIS POINT- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND- THIRTY THREE
MILLION. DOLLARS OR- TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS SO- SO. IF WE CAN GET
THAT. CLARIFIED THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL. SO THE WAY I
UNDERSTAND IT. THE MORE WITH
THE MORE WE TALK ABOUT IT. THE
SMALLER SUBSET IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE NOT. WILL NOT
CYCLING THROUGH FIFTEEN TIMES
BEFORE THEY ARE FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
THAT'S THE OTHER SUBSET. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS RIGHT NOW
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO. BE ABLE TO
MEET THE DEADLINE OF SIXTY DAYS
FROM WHEN SOMEONE IS FOUND BEEN
FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL UNTIL THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE BEEN TREATED AND
PREPARED. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK ON RIGHT THAT
THE STATE. BECAUSE THERE'S SO
MANY WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO TREAT
THOSE PEOPLE SO WE'RE SAYING
LET'S LET THE COUNTIES DO
WHAT'SAND THAT'S WHERE THEY
ARE ANYWHERE ANYWAY. AND WILL
WE WILL TRY TO INCENTIVIZE THEM
BUT- IT AGREED I DON'T KNOW
HOW. HOW WE INCENTIVIZE THEM
MEDIA FOLKS ALREADY I OUR
COUNTY THAT. THAT HAVE CYCLED
THROUGH AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN THESE ARE NOT STRANGERS
TO THAT SYSTEM. THAT WE'RE NOW
SAYING OKAY NO YOU GET THE
MONEY TO STAND TRIAL WITH OUR
SUPPORT. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT BEING
ABLE TO MEET THE SIXTY DAY IS
THAT ONE OF YOUR OUTCOMES THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO MEET. WHAT
ACROSS ALL OF OUR PROPOSALS
THAT IS ULTIMATELY THE GOAL IS
ANYBODY THAT LANDS ON. THE WAIT
LIST. IS ADMITTED WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS. THREE I'M NOT BEEN
MOUNTED TIME THAT IT TAKES TO
ACTUALLY RESTORE SOMEBODY. AND
THEY THEY CAN STAY WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM UP TO TWO YEARS BUT IT'S
THE IT'S ABOUT SIXTY DAYS
AROUND MUNITION ONLINE. AND
TRYING TO CONNECT PEOPLE. THEM
WITHIN THAT TIME LINES INTO A
PROGRAM SO THEY GET TIMELY
ACCESS TO TREATMENT TO BE
RESTORED SO THAT THEY CAN BASE
THEIR- THEY'RE CHARTS- BEYOND
HAPPY. AND THE PROCESS- I WOULD
SAY ABOUT IT. FROM A FROM THE
PROGRAM. ITSELF YES IT'S ONE OF
THOSE ALL OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT
WE ARE WORKING TOWARDS ALL OF
BE. THE DIVERSION AND BEAT HERE
ARE. YEARS OF ADDING POSSIBLY
AT THE STATE HOSPITALS. OUR BE
PARTNERING WITH THE JAILS TO
EXPAND CAPACITY INTO THE JAILS
AND THEN BE COMMUNITY BASED.
PROGRAM WITH LA AND NOW OUR IN
THE EXPANSION OF COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES AND NOW THIS-
THE CDP ARE ALL WORKING TOWARDS
THAT GOAL AND MAKING SURE THAT
ANY DEFENDANT. WHO GETS- I.
FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY
ARE IN THE STATE. GETS ACCESS
TO TREATMENT- IN IN A TIMELY
MANNER SO THAT THEY CAN
PROGRESS THROUGH THEIR DUE
PROCESS AND NOT ALTERNATELY THE
GOAL NO MATTER WHAT INDIA. BUT.
A PROPOSAL- WITH RESPECT TO
THIS PURPOSE- IT. IS IT IT'S
KIND OF BAD. LAST THE OPERATE.
THAT THE DEBT WHEN THEY CONTACT
US WE- THEM. AND THEN WITH SOME
THEM BACK TO BACK YOU KNOW. AND
THEY REALLY ARE TO FINE WE- AND
THAT. TO THEIR- WHAT FIND IS
THAT IN. LIKE WORKING WITH NOT
IN THIS. BE REST. PROGRAMS HAVE
THE COUNTY HAS ALL OF THE
SERVICES AND CAN IN HER WORK
ACOSTA JUSTICE PARTNERS. AND TO
BE ABLE TO REALLY CONNECT ART
THE COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS TO
THE BROADER CONTINUUM OF
SERVICES TO REALLY- I'M MORE
HOLISTICALLY TREAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL AND PROVIDE OPTIONS
FOR- AT BAR SHE'S CALLED THAT
PERSON PRESSES AFTER THAT AND
THERE MAY THEY'VE BEEN RESTORED
TO COMPETENCY SO. IT'S. MORE OF
A- AN OPPORTUNE FOR BY OUT FOR
THE IN THE THEN JUST SENDING A
MISTAKE IN RE BACKED COURT. AND
NOW WE HAVE ALL OF THE PARTNERS
IN THE COMMUNITY TO TOUCHING
THIS PERSON WANTS TO BECOME IS
TO BE AND WORKING TOGETHER TO
TRY TO FIND. AT TO PROVIDE THE
BEST OUTCOMES FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL. AGAIN I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY IS. ARGUING WITH WITH
THE- WITH THE DESIRE DR. SO I
THINK AGAIN AT THE- CLARITY'S
HELPFUL SO FIRST OF ALL- WHAT
YOU JUST EXPLAIN TO ME NOW
MAKES ME THINK IS THIS PROGRAM
ABOUT AND AGAIN VERY WORTHY
GOAL THAT YOU HAVE YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S ADMITTED TO THE
STATE HOSPITAL YOU DO YOUR
TREATMENT NOW YOU DISCHARGED
THEM AND NOW YOU WANT BE SURE
TO GET SERVICES AFTER THIS
START SO THEY DON'T. MIGHT
CRASH AGAIN WHICH IS CERTAINLY
VERY IMPORTANT BUT THAT SOUNDS
DIFFERENT AND- I'M NOT SURE HOW
TO HELP WITH THE SIXTY DAYS
BUT- BUT IT'S AGAIN I THINK IS
A WORTHY GOAL IN ITSELF SO I
THINKS. TO SOME CLARITY ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE- FOCUSING ON IT AND
NOW AGAIN WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT
PROGRAMS TO HELP PEOPLE AFTER
DISCHARGE FROM THE HOSPITAL SO-
IF THERE'S SOMETHING NEEDS TO
BE DONE THAT FIGHT AGAINST. I
STILL SENT SOME I GUESS
CONFUSION NOT NOT WORTHINESS
BUT CONFUSION ABOUT WHERE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THESE
PARTICULAR FUNDS AND HOW DO WE
METRIC THE SUCCESSOR NIGHT OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND- IF THERE
NEEDS ALSO BE A PROGRAM TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE BETTER IN
A GREAT COMMUNITY SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
DISTRACTIONS THE HOSPITAL'S
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WANT TO BE.
PART OF THAT AND THINK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF FUNDING
OR OTHER TYPES OF THINGS WE
NEED TO DIRECTED THAT DIRECTION
AS WELL. YEAH I THINK MAYBE I
CREATED A LITTLE BIT OF
CONFUSION I'M NOT IN THAT THIS
ISN'T AROUND JUST SERVING THE
POPULATION THAT IS DIFFERENT
FROM THE HOSPITALS. AS THE CCP
IS AROUND THE COMMUNITY THAT
COUNTS BE TAKING RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE I. IS TI AND THAT AND
GET ADMITTING THAT I INSTANCE
OF THEIR PROGRAMS AND ALL OF
THAT COUNTY WORKING TOGETHER.
THAT IS THAT THE PARTNERS IN
THE COUNCIL WORKING TOGETHER TO
A TREAT THAT INDIVIDUAL
THERE'LL BE A FEW THAT WILL
COME TO THE STATE HOSPITAL THEY
NEEDED A HIGHER LEVEL OF
TREATMENT AND WOULD ENGAGE WITH
THE COUNTY. BUT ULTIMATELY THE
LION'S SHARE OF THE POPULATION
AND- WHO WE CONTRACT WITH THE
COUNTY WILL BE TREATED IN THE
COUNTY ON THE SERVER BY THE
COUNCIL. FOR WELL. I LOOK
FORWARD OF THE CLEAR PROPOSED-
INTERNET FEW MONTHS- AND
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN WORK WITH L.
A. O. AND HELPING US BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE AGAIN AT ALL THE
BORROWER THE THINGS WE TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW IT WILL BE VERY
SUPPORT OF WHAT YOU ALL THE
DIFFERENT ITEMS YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE JUST. HOPEFULLY WE
HAVE A BETTER WHAT WE'RE DOING.
IN TERMS OF THE FOR THE
SPENDING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOUNG WILL DEFINITELY WORK
BETTER TRYING TO FIVE FIVE AND
IT IN THAT. MISSION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IT'S COMPLICATED. IS
COMPLICATED. AT ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT HELLO CHRIS CDNS. ERECTOR
FOR FORENSIC SERVICES AGAIN.
THIS IS MY LAST ISSUE OKAY
FOLLOW ME. FROM IN THIS ISSUE
EIGHT CONDITIONAL RELEASE
PROGRAM- THAT MOBILE FORENSIC
ASSERTIVE COMMUNITY TREATMENT
TEAMS ARE SO THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
EIGHT MILLION ON GOING ALONG
WITH CHIU POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
AN EXPANSION OF CONRAD SERVICES
BY IMPLEMENTING A MOBILE
TREATMENT TEAMS. THAT'S BASED
ON THE FORENSIC ASSERTIVE
COMMUNITY TREATMENT MODEL OF
CARE TO EXPAND THE CONTINUUM OF
OPTIONS FOR CLIENTS THAT ARE
SERVED THROUGH THE CONDITIONAL
RELEASE PROGRAM. THOSE TWO THIS
PRO. BY PARTNERING WITH NEW
PROVIDERS OR AUGMENTING
EXISTING CONTRACTS WITH OUR
CURRENT. PROVIDERS THIS LEVEL
OF CARE WILL BE LEVERAGED TO
EXPAND COMMUNITY TREATMENT
OPTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE ALREADY COMMITTED TO THE
STATE HOSPITALS EITHER AS AN
OFFENDER AT- WITH MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER. OR NOT GUILTY BY
REASON OF INSANITY. HAVING THE
ABILITY TO PLACE MORE HOSPITAL
PATIENTS IN THE COMMUNITY WILL
ALLOW. OUR DEPARTMENT TO
BACKFILL SOME OF THOSE VACATED
STATE HOSPITAL BEDS WHICH I
ISSUES PENDING PLACEMENT D. S.
H. THIS FUNDING WILL SUPPORT
HOUSING TREATMENT AND SUPPORT
STAFF. CAN'T LIVE SUPPORT COSTS
WHICH IS CLOTHING FOOD
ETCETERA- AS WELL AS SOME START
UP IN PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS A ONE TIME BASIS ARE
RELATED TO THE ACTIVATION OF
NEW HOUSING SITES. IMPLEMENTING
A FACT MODEL OF CARE WITHIN
CONRAD WOULD- ONE IT'LL HELP US
EXPLAIN EXPAND- THE NUMBER OF-
AND- STATE HOSPITAL PATIENTS
WHO CAN BE ELIGIBLE FOR
CONTRACT PLACEMENT BECAUSE-
ONLINE EIGHT. CENTRALIZE CLINIC
MODEL CHAIR WHICH IS HOW OUR
CURRENT CONRAD SERVICES ARE SET
UP- SERVICES WILL BE PRIMARILY
DELIVERED AT THE CLIENTS
RESIDENTS AND ASSIGN TEAMS
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO RESPOND
TO THEM TWENTY FOUR SEVEN- THIS
REALLY ESTABLISHES A FLEXIBLE
MODEL OF CARE THAT COULD BE
RESPONSIVE TO GET THE NEEDS- OF
OUR HIGHER NEED HIGHER RISK
PATIENTS AND WILL ALLOW. US TO
PROVIDE A MORE SUPPORTIVE
TRANSITION FOR INDIVIDUALS
RELEASING- FROM- YOU KNOW
INSTITUTIONALIZATION ARE FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME IT ALSO
HELPED TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PROVIDERS TO SEE HOUSING IN
A BROADER RADIUS AND IS WHAT IS
CURRENTLY USED- AND SO WE'RE
REALLY HOPING TO TAP INTO A
LARGER INVENTORY OF AVAILABLE
HOUSING POTENTIALLY AT FAR.
LOWER RATES THAN WHAT WE WOULD
BE CURRENTLY PAY- AND THEN IN
ON A I WOULD KNOW THAT IN PRIOR
YEAR BUDGET ESTIMATES WE'VE
DISCUSSED THE CHALLENGES WITH
SECURING HOUSING AND- THE
COMPETITION AMONG THE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROVIDERS-
WHERE WE'RE ALL SEEKING TO
PLACE CLIENTS IN THE LIMITED
NUMBER OF WORKING CARE
FACILITIES AND ROOM AND BOARD
RESIDENCES AND SO WE REALLY
THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL- ARE
SEEKING TO ADDRESS THIS
CHALLENGE THREE SECURING SOME
MASTER LEASE CONTRACTS WITH
HOUSING PROVIDERS SO THAT WE
CAN ESTABLISH A DEDICATED-
CONRAD RESIDENCES WHERE DOES
TREATMENT SERVICES CAN BE
DELIVERED. IN TERMS OF OUR
ASSUMPTIONS WE ARE ESTIMATING-
IN ANNUAL COSTS- BAND- SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND- BAD- IN TOTAL
THIS PROPOSAL AND I WOULD GIVE
THIS AN EXPANSION OF A HUNDRED
BEDS. AND THAT SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WOULD SUPPORT THAT
STAFFING- OPERATIONAL AND
CLIENT SPECIFIC COSTS. IN
ADDITION TO THOSE ONGOING COSTS
P. ARE ALSO PROPOSING SOME
START UP COSTS ACTIVATION OF
THOSE ADS AND HAVE ESTIMATED A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER HOUSING
SITE ONE. ENDEAVOR DIRECTOR CAN
I ON THIS ISSUE AND THEN WHEN
WE HAVE A ANOTHER TEN AFTER
THIS THAT THE RIGHT UP WAS VERY
GOOD ON ALL OF THESE OF MAYBE
WE CAN JUST- AND ORDERS THAT
WERE NOT. A IN LIGHT OF COVERT
AS WELL WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE IN A ROOM ALTOGETHER TOO
LONG IF WE CAN MAYBE JUST TO
THE HIGHLIGHTS AND MOVE ON.
YOUR IS ACTUALLY THOSE ARE THE
HIGHLIGHT OKAY WELL THERE WE GO.
APOLOGIZE THAT'S OKAY SO. HELLO
WE'RE GONNA FINANCE. BUT PATH
TOP OKAY LET'S MOVE ON. NUMBER
NINE TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS. IN
THEIR MORNING TECHNICAL INSIGHT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TECHNIK EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM WE GOT WELL
THE NICE LIST. GOOD MORNING
BROWN HAUSER DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS AND-
COLLEGES PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL IN
LIGHT OF MANAGER'S COMMENTS.
OPERATION NINE THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS REQUEST THE
NET ZERO TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS
YOU PERMANENTLY REALIGNED
EXISTING POSITION EXISTING
RESOURCES IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AN ONGOING TO
PROPERLY ALIGNED BUDGET
POSITION OF AUTHORITY WITH
ANTICIPATED. EXPENDITURES AS
EXAMPLE REQUESTED ADJUSTMENTS
POSITIONS THAT REPRESENT
STATEWIDE OVERSIGHT AND POLICY.
DEVELOPMENT FUNCTIONS SUCH AS
THE CLINICAL OPERATIONS
ADVISORY COUNCIL ARE PROPOSED
TO BE REALIGNED TO THE D. S. H.
SACRAMENTO BUDGET OR REALIGNING
POSITIONS ARE EXPENDITURES
SCHEDULED. NDS YES H.
SACRAMENTO'S BUDGET. BUT SIR
HOSPITAL SPECIFIC FUNCTIONS. IN
SUMMARY REQUEST IS NOT
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
OR POSITION FORTY TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS ARE INTENDED TO
MORE ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
ESTATES OPERATIONS AND HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND IF ANYONE
WANTS TO SEE EVERY POSITION IN
DETAIL IT IS IN THE AT THE
DOCUMENT THE AGENDA THAT WAS
PUBLISHED. ANYTHING FROM ALEJO.
THE PERMANENT FINANCE BUT PAN
OKAY NUMBER TEN. HEALTH
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
AGAIN TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE PROTECTED
HEALTH INFORMATION
IMPLEMENTATION PROPOSAL YES H.
REQUEST EXTENDING EIGHT
CURRENTLY FILLED LIMITED TERM
ACCOUNTING POSITIONS FOR TWO
YEARS AND NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. IN
JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN YES AGING
PLUMMETED FITS CAL FROM THE
LEGACY ACCOUNTING SYSTEM CAL
STARS YES IT IS ONE OF THE
LIMITED NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS
WHERE SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
THE S. H. IS INVOICES CONTAIN
CONFIDENTIAL AND SENSITIVE
INFORMATION INCLUDING PATIENT
DATA THAT FALLS UNDER MANDATED
HIPAA COMPLIANCE. I WITH NEW
ELECTRONICS SYSTEMS AND
PROCESSES INTRODUCED THE NEED
FOR D. S. H. TO DEVELOP
PROTECTION MEASURES TO PREVENT
EXPOSURE PROTECTED HEALTH
INFORMATION INCLUDING AUDITING
AND INCIDENT RESPONSE TO
SAFEGUARD INTERNAL CONTROLS. AS
SUCH DISTASTE DEVELOPED A HIPPA
COMPLIANT PROCESS FOR
PROCUREMENT CLAIM ADJUDICATION
CLAIM PAYMENT OF INVOICES TO
EXTERNAL PROVIDERS IS AGE
DEVELOPING DATABASE SYSTEM TO
STANDARDIZE THE PROCESS OF
CAPTURING MEDICAL INVOICE DATA
AND BE IDENTIFYING PROTECTED
HEALTH INFORMATION THE PAYMENTS
CAN STILL OCCUR TIMELY TO
OUTSIDE MEDICAL MEMBERS BUT
WILL NOT INCLUDE ANY PROTECTED
HEALTH INFORMATION. SINCE THE
S. H. CONTINUES TO RELY ON THIS
PROCESS AND IMPLEMENT THE
APPROPRIATE PROTOCOLS AND
WORKLOAD TO PROTECT PROTECTED
HEALTH INFORMATION YES H.
REQUEST EXTENDING THE POSITIONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROCESSING
THESE OUTSIDE MEDICAL INVOICES
TIMELY AND PROTECTING PATIENT
HEALTH INFORMATION WITH THAT I
HAPPEN TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT. FINANCE
HELLO. SUFFIX PLANET TO DOCTOR.
NO THANK YOU MUCH MADE KEEP THE
IN. IN THE DATA PRIVATE OKAY A
NUMBER TWELVE PATIENT. THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO THOUSAND. WE
HAVE A LOT OF. ANNAPOLIS I'M
SORRY. ELEVEN INCREASE COURT
APPEARANCES. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR CHRISTINE TO COUNTY CHIEF
COUNSEL FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS. I'M HERE ON
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN INCREASED
COURT APPEARANCES IN PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST- THIS
PROPOSAL IS SEEKING TO EXTEND
FIVE AND A HALF LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS. FOR AN ADDITIONAL
TWO YEARS THAT WE ORIGINALLY
SEVE RECEIVE THEM BUDGET YOU'RE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. THESE
POSITIONS ARE DUE TO INCREASED
WORKLOAD- FROM CRIMINALLY FROM
THE HIGHEST YOU WAIT LIST AS WE
WILL DISCUSS THE- I A FEW
REFERRALS HAVE OUTPACED. THE
ABILITY OF THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADMIT PATIENTS WHICH IS
GENERATED A WAIT LIST- THAT
WEIGHTLESS HAS COST CONCERNS BY
THE SUPERIOR COURTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. OF QUESTIONING OUT
OF TIME THAT ARE ICY COOL THE
FUNDS WE CAN COUNTY JAIL BEFORE
THEY ARE MADE IT TO THE SHRC OF
COMPETENCE RESTORATION
TREATMENT. BECAUSE OF THOSE
DELAYS COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
HAD ISSUED ORDERS TO SHOW CAUSE
AGAINST U. S. H. THINKING TO
HOLD US IN CONTEMPT TO EXPLAIN
WHY THE PATIENTS HAVE NOT BEEN
NEEDED IN A TIMELY MANNER. AS
WELL AS SEEKING SANCTIONS
AGAINST THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THOSE DELAYED ADMISSIONS. IDEAS
SIX LEGAL DIVISIONS ATTORNEYS
MUST APPEAR AND DEFEND THE
DEPARTMENT IN EACH OF THOSE
ORDERS TO SHOW CAUSE TO EXPLAIN
THE EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS OUR
DEPARTMENT HAS UNDERTAKEN. TO
ADDRESS THE I JUST YOU WAIT
LIST. WE'VE SEEN THE AVERAGE
APPEARANCE RATE FOR D. S. H.
LEGAL DIVISION ATTORNEYS MORE
THAN DOUBLED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN- IN RESPONSE TO THESE
ORDERS TO SHOW CAUSE. WE HAVE
ALSO SEEN OUR PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT REQUEST ALMOST DOUBLED FROM
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AROUND TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO NOW OVER
FIVE HUNDRED. SO THIS PROPOSAL
SEEKS TO ADD ANOTHER TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM FIRST RETRAIN
POSITIONS A LEGAL ANALYST A
LEGAL SECRETARY IN A PART TIME
POSITION AT OUR HOSPITAL KALINA
WHICH HAS THE BULK OF THE-
KERRY REQUEST. I COULD TRY TO
LONG TERM. FOR SOME HUNDRED AND-
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. A FINANCE. HELLO
DEPEND THE SEVENTY COMING I
GUESS WILL FOR A FOCUSED THE
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE THAT-
TIMELINES WE GET UNDER SIXTY
DAYS SO I GUESS THAT'S APROPOS
PREVIOUS EXPRESSION. YES IF THE
WEIGHTLESS REDUCE WE WOULD SEE
WHO CONSIDER THE NEED FOR THESE
RESOURCES MAYBE YES AFTER.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
WILL MOVE ON TO NUMBER TWELVE.
GOOD MORNING OF STERLING PRICE
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
STATE HOSPITALS. THE DEPARTMENT
IS REQUESTING THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND GENERAL FUND
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND I'M GOING TO EXPAND
PATIENT EDUCATION SERVICES AT
THE S. H. COALINGA. OUR GOAL IS
TO OFFER COMPATIBLE EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES FOR COALINGA PATIENTS
AS WE DO WITH OUR OTHER
HOSPITALS IMPROVE PATIENT
OUTCOMES THE NEW SERVICES WOULD
INCLUDE SPECIAL EDUCATION.
ADULT BASIC EDUCATION AND HIGH
SCHOOL EQUIVALENCY PROGRAMS.
CURRENTLY CALLING IT HAS
LIMITED RESOURCES AND IS ONLY
ABLE TO PROVIDE PROGRAMS SUCH
AS COLLEGE DISTANCE LEARNING
COMPUTER SKILLS AND VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION. APPROVAL WILL ALLOW
US TO EXPAND EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES FOR PATIENTS EN MASSE
THE EDUCATION PROGRAMS PROVIDED
THAT OUR OTHER FOR HOSPITALS-
WITH THAT ANY QUESTIONS. BERMAN
FINANCE. HELLO. NO TO CERTIFY
HER AGAIN OKAY NUMBER THIRTY
MEDIC AND PHARMACEUTICAL
BILLING SYSTEM. WILLIAM BRENT
HOUSE OR APARTMENT STATE
HOSPITALS I'M SPEAKING TO THE
MEDICAL AND PHARMACEUTICAL
BILLING SYSTEM REQUEST YES H.
REQUESTS ONE POINT- I. T.
POSITION AND SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL YEARS
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THROUGH ISCAL YEAR TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE TO ENHANCE SYSTEM
FUNCTIONALITY FUNCTIONALITY THE
COST RECOVERY SYSTEM TO CAPTURE
BILL AND RECOVER ELIGIBLE
PATIENT COST OF CARE
REIMBURSEMENTS AND TELL DSHS
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED AN
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD. WITH
THE ADDITION OF THESE RESOURCES
D. S. H. WILL BE ABLE TO
PRIORITIZE SYSTEM CHANGE
REQUESTS MORE TIMELY WHICH ONE
ABLE D. S. H. TO HAVE ABILITY
TO BILL FOR SERVICES THAT ARE
NOT. BEING CAPTURED OR BILL TO
MEDICARE SUCH AS MEDICARE PART
A DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND
TELEMEDICINE. THE I. T. MISTER
WILL BE ABLE TO ADDRESS.
FUNCTIONALITY WITHIN THE COST
RECOVERY SYSTEM TO ADDRESS A
COMPLAINT BUSINESS AND LEGAL
FUNCTIONS RELATED TO PROPER
CODING. BILLING AND COLLECTIONS
OF THIRTY THIRD PARTY RESOURCES.
IN RESPONSE TO OUR AGENDA
QUESTION NUMBER TWO UNDER
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
PATIENTS AND FAMILIES ARE
LIABLE FOR THE COST OF CARE AND
THE SEARCH IS REQUIRED TO
RECOUP COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CARE AND TREATMENT PROVIDED
IDEA STAGE. THERE'S ALSO A
MEDICARE REQUIREMENT THAT STATE
LAW REQUIRES COLLECTION EFFORTS
FOR COST OF CARE. PLEASE NOTE
THE ESSEX DOES RECOGNIZE THAT
MANY PATIENTS DO NOT HAVE
ASSETS OR INABILITY TO PAY FOR
THEIR CARE. A LIABILITY IS
BASED ON THE COMMITMENT TYPE OF
THE FISH PATIENT AND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN JAIL OR PRISON
UNDER NOT UNDER THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF PSH ARE
GOVERNED UNDER DIFFERENT
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS THAT.
MAY NOT INCUR SIMILAR LIABILITY
OF COST OF CARE. SPEAKING TO A
GENERAL QUESTION OUR NUMBER
THREE ARE FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THROUGH TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY THE AVERAGE NET
REVENUE RECOVERY FROM MEDICARE
AND PRIVATE PAY AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR. THE PATIENT
COST RECOVERY SECTION
OPERATIONAL COST IS
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
PLEASE NO PATIENT COST RECOVERY
SECTION IS ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
COLLECTING THE COUNTY LPS
REIMBURSEMENTS WHICH YIELDED
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
MILLION ANDFISCAL YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN MILLION AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. I WITHOUT
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYTHING DEPARTMENT
FINANCE EARLIER. THANK YOU TO
SO JUST TO CLARIFY YOU
OBVIOUSLY- SO YOU SAID THE
STATE CODE BUT MEDICARE
REQUIRES US TO DO THIS. I GUESS
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT A
CONDITION OF PARTICIPATION FROM
MEDICARE THAT THE STATE DOES
COLLECT ON COST OF CARE IN
ORDER TO SEEK MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT ON BEHALF OF
PATIENTS. THAT AND DO WE KNOW
HOW MUCH HOW MUCH DO WE GET
FROM MEDICARE- RELATED TO THIS.
OF I THINK IT'S APPROXIMATELY
AROUND A TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY BUT HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH THE SPECIFICS. OKAY
BECAUSE I'VE OBVIOUSLY LIVED OF
THE BALANCES IS THAT IF WE
DON'T DO IT THEN WE GIVE UP OUR
MEDICARE RIGHT AND IS IT IS
VERY SMALL PORTION- THE
QUESTIONS WOULD THAT BE WORTH
IT OR NOT BUT IT'S LARGE
OBVIOUSLY UNFORTUNATELY WILL
HAVE TO. KEEP PURSUING PEOPLE
FOR RESOURCES THEY DON'T HAVE
SELF THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY- YEAH OKAY THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
INFECTION PREVENTED PREVENTION
S. ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW. GOOD
MORNING ALLEN BACHMAN
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR STATEWIDE
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT. YES H. IS
REQUESTING THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND IN GENERAL FUND
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND ONGOING FORGE TO PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO ESTABLISH
INFECTION PREVENTION NEST.
FORTY S. H. METROPOLITAN AND
DSHS NAPA- IN ACCORDANCE WITH
REQUIREMENTS SET FORTH IN AB
TWENTY SIX FOR FORTY FOUR I
STATUTES OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
SECTION TWELVE FIFTY FIVE POINT
NINE OF THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE- DURING THE PANDEMIC OF
CDPH IS TO NUMEROUS ALL
FACILITIES LETTERS THAT
PROVIDED- SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS. FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES TO
ADDRESS CODE NINETEEN BOTH
METROPOLITAN AND NAPA OPERATE
LICENSE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES WITH ONE HUNDRED AND
TWO SKILLED NURSING BEDS AT
METROPOLITAN AND THIRTY SIX
FIELD NURSING BEDS AT DCH NAPA.
THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE
CONTINUOUS NURSING TREATMENT
FOR BOTH FORENSICALLY AND
CIVILLY COMMITTED PATIENTS AND
ARE LICENSED AND REGULATED. BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- IN ORDER TO MEET
REQUIREMENTS- OF ALL FACILITIES
LETTER TWENTY FIFTY TWO WHICH
REQUIRED- INFECTION IS THE
INFECTION PREVENTION MUST BE
PUT IN PLACE ON A FULL TIME
BASIS YES H. HAD TO RE DIRECT
NURSING STAFF RESOURCES- WHEN
THIS REQUIREMENT BECAME
PERMANENT AS RESULT OF THE
PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR- THIS IS
NOW A PERMANENT REQUIRE AND SO
WE'RE ASK FOR THOSE BECAUSE TO
GET. TO THAT ON GOING TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR ONGOING
INFECTION CONTROL PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES FOR SKILLED NURSING
PROGRAMS INCLUDING MONITORING
ADHERENCE TO INFECTION CONTROL
PROTOCOLS SURVEILLANCE OUTBREAK
AND ESTIMATIONS TRACING.
QUALITY ASSESSMENTS AND STAFF
TRAINING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE AND WE NOTICED THAT CAME
FROM OUR COLLEAGUE THAT DOCTOR
WOULD THE CHAIR OF ASSEMBLY
ANNA. FOR A PHANTOM THIS.
DOCTOR PAN. THE NEW YORKER IT'S
A GREAT IDEA YOU VERY MUCH. ON
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN ONE TIME
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ALLOCATION.
MORNING AND BRING HOUSING
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITAL COMEY
SPEAKING TO ISSUES FIFTEEN
THROUGH ISSUES EIGHTEEN SO
APPRECIATE BEARING WITH ME HERE
TRANSACTION LIKE A BRANCH OKAY.
WELL SPEAKING TO THE ONE TIME
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ALLOCATION
PSH REQUEST A ONE TIME FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION. WHICH WOULD BE
AVAILABLE OVER THREE YEARS TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SPECIAL REPAIRS AND
OTHER REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
PROJECTS ACROSS THE S. H. IS BY
STATE HOSPITALS. I AM PROJECTS
INCLUDE THOSE INCLUDES THOSE
RELATED TO FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY
AND CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
SPECIFICALLY SUCH I DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS COULD BE
INCLUDE PLUMBING REPAIRS
HEATING VENTILATION AIR
CONDITIONING REPLACEMENT. DOOR
REPAIRS REPLACING BOILERS.
COURTYARD'S INPATIENT AREA-
AREAS IN ROOMS- BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND DSHS EMPRESS
STRUCTURE SPANS FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR BUILDING SENT.
OVER TWENTY SIX HUNDRED ACRES
OF LAND WHICH IS EIGHT AGING
AND CRITICAL BUILDING SYSTEMS
HAVE EXCEEDED THEIR USEFUL
LIFE. I SAW ADDRESSING MINOR
PROBLEMS BEFORE THEY ESCALATE
IS ESPECIALLY CRUCIAL AS TO
PREVENT HEALTH AND SAFETY RISKS
TO PATIENTS AS WELL AS STOP
OCCUPYING BUILDINGS. ARE WITH
THAT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE FIFTEEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. ANYTHING FROM THE
PARTNER FINANCE. THE A. L. WE
HAVE THE AND AGAIN THE LIST IS-
IN OUR AGENDA ANYBODY CARES TO.
LOOK AT HOW MUCH IT COST TO
REPAIR A SINKHOLE IN A PARKING
LOT. M. BUT I LIVE IN A-
HUNDRED PLUS YEAR OLD HOUSE SO
I KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
BUILDINGS H. AND IF YOU DON'T
TAKE CARE OF IT. SOON JUST LIKE
OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM WE PAY
A LOT FOR IT MORE FOR IT LATER.
OKAY A DOCTOR PAN ANYTHING
HONEST YES JUST BRIEFLY- AGAIN
THE SERVICE FOR THIS- AND I
KNOW WE HAVE SOME OTHER ITEMS
ALSO IN TERMS OF REPAIRS AND
MAINTENANCE I DON'T KNOW IF.
THERE IS A SORT OF BROADER
REPORT AS TO WHAT'S ACTUALLY ON
THE LIST SO. OBVIOUSLY THESE
URGENT- SO AND YOU'RE ALSO
GOING TO TALK ABOUT SOME OTHER
THINGS- WHICH THE WHAT THE REST
OF THE BACKLOG LOOKS LIKE- SO
LIKE ANY LIKE- SAMPLE WE DO
RESERVE STUDIES. HAVE
ASSOCIATIONS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT FOR OVERALL CAPITAL
MAINTENANCE. THERE'S SOME
DOCUMENT LIKE THAT. THAT AREAS
LOOKED AT OR SOMETHING THAT BE.
HELPFUL TO SO WE CAN PROJECTED
FUTURE THANK YOU. OKAY- RIGHT
WE NOTICED ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE EXPENSIVE THINGS ON
HERE WOULD BE A NEW ROOF OR BAD
BRING REDOING FIRE LINES WILL
WE ALL KNOW HOW MUCH THOSE
THINGS COST OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- LET'S MOVE ON THEN TO.
ISSUE NUMBER. AT SIXTEEN
METROPOLITAN CONSOLIDATION OF
POLICE OPERATIONS. ANOTHER
CAPITAL OUTLAYS THAT YOU MISTER
ELDER AGAINST YES THAT'S
CORRECT THAT ISN'T HE OKAY. THE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST TWENTY TWO
MILLION FROM THE PUBLIC
BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTION FUND FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THE
METROPOLITAN CONSOLIDATION OF
POLICE OPERATIONS PROJECT THE
NEW BUILDING WILL ALLOW FOR THE
CONSOLIDATION OF HOSPITAL
POLICE SERVICES INTO A SINGLE
LOCATION AND INCLUDE THE
DEMOLITION OF A SEISMICALLY
DEFICIENT BUILDING. ARE THESE
NEW BUILDINGS WILL BE
DESIGNATED AS A CENTRAL
SERVICES BUILDING WHICH WILL BE
THE ONLY BUILDING ON THE PSH
METROPOLITAN CAMPUS MEETING THE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS- FOR
HOSPITAL POLICE BUILDINGS. ON
THE SITE WORK SPECIFICALLY
WOULD CONSIST OF A DEMOLITION
OF FIVE EXISTING BUILDINGS AND
ASSOCIATED IMPROVEMENTS TO
INCLUDE SITE CLEARING GRADING
PAVING FOR ROADS AND PARKING
RETAINING WALLS AS REQUIRED AND
SITE UTILITIES. ARE THE CURRENT
POLICE OPERATION ENTITIES ARE
CURRENTLY LOCATED IN BUILDINGS
WITH SIGNIFICANT HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES AND NON
COMPLIANCE WITH CORRECTIVE
REQUIREMENTS FOR SEISMIC
SAFETY. OF THE PROJECT IS
ANTICIPATED TO AWARD THE
CONTRACT IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND PROJECTED FOR
COMPLETION IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WITH. THAT HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ANYTHING FROM TO
FIND. OKAY DR GRANT. ALL RIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON TO THAT HYDRONIC
LOOP REPLACEMENT MR HOUSING.
YES I REQUEST FIFTY POINT FIVE
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF
THE PSH CALMING HYDRONIC LOOP
REPLACEMENT PROJECT THAT'S
QUITE QUITE A MOUTHFUL THIS
PROJECT REPLACES THE SEVERELY
CORRODED AND DETERIORATED
DETERIORATED HYDRONIC LOOP
PIPING SYSTEM WITH A COMPLETELY
NEW PIPING SYSTEM WHICH WILL
OFFICIALLY PROVIDE HOT WATER
AND HEATING TO FACILITIES
INCLUDING HAITIAN OCCUPIED
BUILDINGS. NEW HI DJANA GROUP
WILL PROVIDE A COMPLETE
DISTRIBUTION LOOP CONNECTING TO
SIX EXISTING BUILDINGS AND NINE
BELOW GRADE CONNECTION POINTS-
THE WORK WILL SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDE DEMOLITION A SOIL
COMPACTION MATERIAL TESTING
WELDING INSPECTIONS AND ALL
OTHER ELEMENTS TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECT ON THE PRELIMINARY PLAN
APPROVALS ANTICIPATED IN MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE AN
ESTIMATED PROJECT COMPLETION
DATE OF SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR I AFTER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING FIFTY POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR CONSTRUCTION BUT
PLEASE NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS WORKING ON AN UPDATED COST
ESTIMATES THE REQUEST WILL BE
UPDATED THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCES SPRING FINANCE
LETTER PROCESS- WITH THAT HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYTHING FROM
DEPARTMENT FINANCER LA- OKAY
AND I. HISTORICALLY WE'VE HAD
TO DO. UNDER THE LAST SUBJECT
AREA DO A LOT OF SMALLER- FIXES
ON THIS BIG SYSTEM AND SO NOW
WE'RE JUST GOING TO SAY NOW
IT'S TIME TO JUST REPLACE THE
WHOLE SYSTEM. OKAY BACKGROUND
YEAH. SO ACTUALLY I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS THAT- THE SYSTEMS
ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS OLD I THINK
IT WAS BUILT IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FIVE- THAT SEEMS TO BE.
SHORTER THAN I WOULD. THINK
THAT THE EXPECTED LIFETIME
LIFESPAN OF SUCH A SYSTEM
SHOULD BE. AND DOES POINT OUT
ANALYSIS STORE SOME. ISSUES
AROUND YOU KNOW LEAK THAT IN
TERMS OF THE FLANGES AND SO
FORTH. THOSE WERE REBUILDING
THE SYSTEM SPENDING ANOTHER
FIFTY MILLION WHAT STEPS ARE
BEING TAKEN SO WHAT IS THE
EXPECTED LIFETIME OF THIS NEW
SYSTEM AND WHAT STEPS ARE BEING
TAKEN TO BE SURE THAT THE WORK.
WELL I DON'T KNOW SHE WHAT
STANDARDS WERE APPLIED TO THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE BUT- I GUESS I'M JUST
TRYING TO BE SURE THAT THE
APPROPRIATE STEPS ARE TAKEN SO
THAT WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT LAST
A BIT LONGER GIVEN THE EXPENSE.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
NORMAL PROJECTED LIFESPAN IS OF
A SYSTEM LIKE THIS. WITHOUT
QUESTION I MAY NEED TO DEFER TO
MY CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
NICOLE HICKS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
STATE HOSPITALS OKAY. MISTAKES
YEAH HI THIS IS NICOLE HICKS
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER PER
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
ON IT WAS ANTICIPATED- DURING
THE CONSTRUCTION AND LATER
VALUE ENGINEERED OUT OF THE
PROJECT THE- CERTAIN
PROTECTIONS FOR THE PIPE BEANS
AND THAT WAS A CONSTRUCTION
ISSUE THAT WAS DEALT WITH AT
THAT POINT IN TIME- THEN
REALIZING TO THE CORROSIVE
NATURE OF THE SOILS IN. THE
IMMEDIATE IMPACT OF THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WHEN WE STARTED
TO SEE THE LEAKS MATERIALIZED
IN AS FAR AS THE- AS FAR AS THE
STRATEGIES THAT ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS PROPOSAL YES
INDEED THERE IS A CERTAIN
MATERIALS DEFINITELY BE
CONSIDERED THAT WILL
ENCAPSULATE THE CURRENT PRICING
AND PROVIDED WITH THE
NECESSARY. PROTECTION SO THAT
IS NOT AFFECTED BY THE
CORROSIVE SOILS IT IS A MIX OF
BELOW GRADE AND ABOVE GREAT
CONSTRUCTION ALSO WHICH WILL
FURTHER OP PROVIDE FOR
PROTECTION OF THE- SYSTEM SO
IT'S A WHAT IS THE ANTICIPATED
LIFESPAN THAN OF THIS NEW.
SYSTEM- IT SHOULD BE PRETTY
YEARS SHOULD BE FIFTY YEARS
OKAY. LADENBURG MAINTENANCE
BEING DONE TIMELY OF COURSE YES
OF I AGREE WE HAVE TO DO
ROUTINE MAINTENANCE- BUT ALL
RIGHT SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
FIFTY YEAR LIFESPAN ON THIS
OKAY. WILL BE TURNED OUT BY
THEN BUT- GET A WARRANTY
MYSTICS AREA YEAH OKAY OKAY SO
HOPEFULLY YOU'RE ASSURANCES FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION COMPANY AT
THEIR WARRANTIES THAT THEN. I
REALIZED I GAVE FIFTY YEAR
WARRANTY BUT THAT- ARE
DEPRECIATED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER. AND I THINK IT'S
OUR LAST ONE EIGHTEEN. ENHANCE
TREATMENT UNITS THAT MISTREAT
YOU MISTER HAUSER YES IT IS
CLOSING UP YOU. SO THE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST A
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATION OF
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR INCREASED
CONSTRUCTION COSTS FOR THE
STATEWIDE ENHANCE TREATMENT
UNITS IDEA STAGE ATASCADERO
IDEA STAGE PATTON I'LL BE
ENHANCE TREATMENT UNITS WILL
SERVE PATIENTS WHO ARE AT THE
HIGHEST RISK OF VIOLENCE IN
CANNOT BE SAFELY TREATED IN A
STANDARD TREATMENT EMPIRE
ENVIRONMENT DIRECTOR CLINTON
INFORMATION UPDATE EARLIER IN
AN ISSUE AREA. THIS IS THE
CONSTRUCTION COMPONENT OF THAT
PROGRAM THE ENHANCE TREATMENT
PROGRAM. THE ATASCADERO. IS DUE
TO UP OBJECTS SUSPENSION OF
EIGHT MONTHS DUE TO COBIT
OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL REVISIONS REQUIRED FUEL
CHANGES. HI AN UNFORESEEN SITE
CONDITIONS. THE PATENT SPECIFIC
AUGMENTATION IS NECESSARY DUE
TO OUR PROJECTS PENSION COSTS
AS WELL DO AS WELL AS KOBE
NINETEEN IMPACTS AND DELAYS. ON
THE M. THESE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
ARE NECESSARY TO COMPLETE
CONSTRUCTION- WHICH IS
ANTICIPATED TO BE COMPLETED IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
WITHOUT HAVING TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HELLO SECOND. OKAY I
THINK THAT'S IT MR HOUSER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- AND A BIG THANKS
TO THE DEPARTMENT- FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK AND PRESENTATION
TODAY AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD
TO. GOING FORWARD WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE- PUBLIC COMMENTS
SECTION WE HAVE OUR MODERATOR
ON. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE. IS ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE- I WILL JUST START
OFF BY SAYING DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM ROOM ONE TWELVE.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY IN THAT
ROOM. SO NOW WE WILL MOVE TO
THE MODERATOR- AND MR MODERATOR
MISS MODERATOR. NAME OPERATOR
ARE THERE ANY PEOPLE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU YES WE DO HAVE
TWO PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. AND IF YOU DO WISH TO
COMMENT VIA THE PHONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU YOUR
LINE NUMBER WHEN YOU'RE- MY
NUMBER IS CALLED PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE SIXTEEN LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TYLER ENGAGE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS CONCERNS WITH THAT. THE
UNITY CARE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT BURKE COUNTY
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
POPULATION I'M WE DO NOT HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THAT
BUT- LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING-
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION-
ONCE REDUCE FINALIZED THE
POSITION FIVE MONITOR CONTRACT
THE RESPECT YOU I'M CONCERNED-
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
DOES NOT SET UP COUNTY- WELL.
SIX FEET UNDER THE PROGRAM- IT
INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT- FINANCIAL
RISKS FOR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WITHOUT THE ABILITY. TO
CONTROL THE ON YOU KNOW CARE OR
THE COST OF THE POPULATION
ADEQUATELY. I'M FOR I'VE ONE
EXAMPLE OF THAT PROPOSAL LOOKS
YOU HAVE TO COUNTY START OUT
THE CONTRACT- IN AT THE SAME
TIME HE'D BE INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING. AND WE SEE THAT IT'S
BEEN CHALLENGING AND THERE ARE
NONE THE PLACEMENT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL DO NOT EXIST FOR THE
POPULATION AND WE'RE ALREADY
HAD OUR HIGH LEVEL CARE.
PLACEMENT I'M- AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND SHALL BE WOULD NEED
TO YOU KNOW TO FAILED OUTBACK
BEFORE STEAMING RESPONSE. THE
THAT UNDER THIS PROPOSAL BY-
OFTEN THESE DECISIONS ARE MADE
BY THE COURT WITH THE INPUT AT
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY. AND NOT
BY COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR
EXAMPLE THE PROPOSAL CHARGES
COUNTY THE PREMIUM RATE FIRST
THE HOSPITAL REFERRALS WITH NO
GUARANTEE OF AVAILABLE BAD. IN
A COUNTY VIEWS BEYOND THEIR
ALLOCATION THE RATE CONTINUES
TO INCREASE. AND OFTEN THAT
DECISION THE TIME COMING TO THE
STATE HOSPITAL EVEN UNDER THE
PROPOSAL IS NOT UNDER OUR
CONTROL SO. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS AROUND
THE PROPOSAL BUT WANTED
EXPRESSED CONCERNS BUT I THINK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY. MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS WENT AWAY WITH LESSONS
AND I'M ON POVERTY. REGARDING
ISSUE THIRTEEN ON THE
HOSPITAL'S CHARGE HAITIAN FOR
THE FULL AMOUNT OF MEDICAL CARE
WE THE L. G. OVER AND DOLLARS
IT IS CRUEL AND I'M DEREK FROM
PATIENTS WHO INVOLVED CHIU
DIDN'T PAY HOSPITAL. IN MACON
JAIL PRISONS ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO. WHEN TRUMP AWAY TRIAL IN
THE STATE THEIR CHARGE FOR THE
MIDDLE CARE RAISING EQUITY FOR
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH THE
BILL. VERY FEW PEOPLE CAN UP TO
PAY THE BILLS ESPECIALLY FORMER
WHO CAN WORK DETERMINE
CONDITION. HE'S BILLS BECAUSE
VI<c.cyan> AND AMONG CASE CONNECT</c>
WITH VERY LOW BEING ACTUALLY
COLLECT. IN REGARDS DOCTOR AND
QUESTION THE DEPART HAD BEEN OF.
X. THE STATE. PATIENTS ARE
SCREEN AND CONNECT WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES THE SCHOOL SIMILAR TO
HOSPITAL PRICING ACT YOU MAY BE
OBLIGATION UNDER GUIDED AND
ALLOW TO CAMP OF DEBT WITHOUT
JEOPARDIZE MEDICARE PAYMENT.
JUSTIN WHEN PEOPLE ARE FROM
AFTER WHICH NOT WE SHOULD SEE
CONNECTED INTO THE WITH
SERVICES THAT WILL HELP THEM RE
ENTERS THE NOT THAT'LL WITH
THAT THAT COULD UP FOR SALE.
THEY'LL ASK YOU SEE STOP THE
ONLY AND THEIR FAMILIES THANK
YOU. AND WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN THIS MEETING.